Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 34, Databases. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everyone. So just real quick, I know we promised the episode on Swift it is coming Patrick and I are just really uh it's coming simply Patrick I'm just really trying to learn
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供主机服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 34 期，数据库。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。简单说一下，我知道我们承诺过要做一期关于 Swift 的节目，它已经在路上了。Patrick 和我只是真的……它已经在路上了，Patrick，我只是真的在努力学习
Swift but uh it's taking a little bit longer than definitely I anticipated uh more just because you know we want to uh there's not a whole lot out there right and so um you know a lot of it is just understanding how the language works and things like that. So we'll definitely get to that. But in the meantime, we'll definitely, we have a really awesome show here on databases that. I don't know what you're talking about, man. I already wrote three top of the chart performing App Store games. Oh, yeah?
Swift，但它花的时间比我预期的要长一些。更多是因为，你知道，我们想……外面相关的资料并不多，对吧？所以，你知道，很大程度上只是在理解这门语言是如何工作的，诸如此类。我们肯定会做那一期的。但在此期间，我们这里有一期关于数据库的非常棒的节目。我不知道你在说什么，伙计。我已经写了三款在 App Store 排行榜上名列前茅的游戏了。哦，是吗？
Flappy Patrick. Yeah, and I quit my job. And I'm a billionaire. Oh, man. So from the mailbag, Ash Booth wrote in, and he said, Hey, guys, I discovered the show about a month ago. I'm an AI slash machine learning PhD student, and what's it like to go from academia to you know industry to working uh well they're
《Flappy Patrick》。是的，我辞职了。我现在是亿万富翁。天哪。那么，来自听众来信，Ash Booth 写信说，嘿，伙计们，我大约一个月前发现了这个节目。我是一名人工智能/机器学习方向的博士生，从学术界转到工业界工作是什么感觉？嗯，他们
both they're both working but what's what's it like to go from working at a university uh or or studying at a university to a full-time job maybe i should answer this because i you went straight from elementary school to working i did have a job for most of high school and college. A full-time job. Anyways, so yeah. Well, yeah, you go first and then I'll chime in. I was just joking, actually. Okay.
都在工作，但从在大学工作或在大学学习转到全职工作是什么感觉？也许我应该回答这个问题，因为你是直接从小学毕业就开始工作的。我在高中和大学的大部分时间里确实有一份工作。一份全职工作。总之，是的。好吧，你先说，然后我再补充。我其实是在开玩笑。好吧。
So for me, I only did undergraduate, so four years of college. So I'm not an academic uh long-term student well you did a master's right what i did a master's while i was working so oh i see so you kind of did yeah that makes so i already started working and i had an internship actually after my second year of school so i went to school for two years and i had already worked and i think that eased some of it so i recommend internships are a really good thing oh definitely because engineering internships are almost always good thing. Oh, definitely. Because engineering internships are almost always paid.
对我来说，我只读了本科，也就是四年大学。所以我不是那种长期的学术型学生。嗯，你读了硕士，对吧？我在工作的时候读了硕士，所以……哦，我明白了，所以你算是……是的，这说得通。所以我已经开始工作了，而且我大二之后其实实习过，所以我读了两年书，而且我已经工作过了，我觉得这减轻了一些压力，所以我推荐实习，这是一个非常好的事情。哦，当然，因为工程实习几乎总是一件好事。哦，当然。因为工程实习几乎总是有报酬的。
I've never heard of an unpaid engineering internship. Right. And so you get money. That's cool. And then also, like, it does expose you for, like, you know, going back to school for the remainder of the time to, like, know what to study and what you're interested in and what the real life, I'm doing little quotes here is all about um but i mean i think the biggest transition is from the fact that like an academic is perfectly to say things like always and never and in real life you can't really say those things because you have to bend or break a lot of rules because you may be working on older technology or like the style of your team is just this and even though academically you may be able to show like this style of your team is just this and even though academically
我从来没听说过无薪的工程实习。没错。所以你能拿到钱。那很酷。而且，它确实让你在回到学校完成剩余学业时，知道该学什么，对什么感兴趣，以及现实生活——我这里打个引号——到底是怎么回事。但我的意思是，我认为最大的转变在于，学术界的人非常喜欢说“总是”和“从不”这样的话，而在现实生活中，你不能真的那样说，因为你必须变通或打破很多规则，因为你可能是在使用旧技术，或者你们团队的风格就是这样。即使在学术上你可能能够证明……你们团队的风格就是这样，即使在学术上
you may be able to show like this paper says this this is the more optimal way to do this it's like well we already have coded this we've already invested the time and tested it and you know whatever um just kind of realizing you know like uh we were talking about this um today at lunch that uh you know in python in the Python compiler, there's something called TimSort. And it's named after Tim. And the idea is
你可能能够证明，比如这篇论文说这是实现这一点的最优方式，但现实是，好吧，我们已经写好代码了，我们已经投入了时间并进行了测试，你知道，无论如何……只是意识到，你知道，我们今天午餐时还在谈论这个，在 Python 编译器中，有一个东西叫 TimSort。它是以 Tim 的名字命名的。其理念是
they need to do some kind of sorting. And again, I'm not going to go into the details. I don't even really know the details. But to some extent, part of the Python compiler needed to sort something. But they knew something about the data like they knew certain chunks of the data were already in some kind of order and so tim sort uh you know took advantage of some of the assumptions they could make about the data to sort faster than n log n right which? Which, just to recap, like if you take computer science 101,
他们需要进行某种排序。再说一次，我不会深入细节。我甚至不太了解细节。但在某种程度上，Python 编译器的一部分需要对某些东西进行排序。但他们对数据有所了解，比如他们知道数据的某些部分已经处于某种顺序，所以 TimSort 利用了他们可以对数据做出的某些假设，从而比 O(n log n) 更快地进行排序，对吧？这，简单回顾一下，如果你上过计算机科学 101，
one of the first things you'll learn is that the two fastest sorts, theoretically, quick sort and merge sort, both run in n log n. But Tim sort, you know, given the data that Tim sort works on, runs in faster than n log n. And so the point is, you know, when you get down to industry, you're not working on like theoretically theoretical data. I mean, you're working on practical data that, um, you can make a lot more assumptions on. And so a lot of the theory kind of goes out the window. Yep.
你学到的第一件事就是理论上最快的两种排序，快速排序和归并排序，运行时间都是 O(n log n)。但 TimSort，考虑到它处理的数据，运行速度比 O(n log n) 快。所以重点是，当你进入工业界时，你处理的不是理论上的数据。我的意思是，你处理的是实际的数据，你可以做出更多的假设。所以很多理论在某种程度上就没用了。没错。
That is, that's my biggest thing. I don't know. Yeah. I guess my biggest thing is, uh, um, I kind of look at it this way, like going into academia,
那是，那是我最大的感受。我不知道。是的，我想我最大的感受是，我倾向于这样看，进入学术界，
like as a student or as a faculty or, or what, how as a research assistant or what have you, um, is a lot like owning your own business. Um, like as a research assistant or what have you um is a lot like owning your own business um like as a student you're really in charge of your own fate more than you are as an employee like as a student you can very quickly within a matter of three or four months you can fail out of college right but you know outside of like sexually harassing someone or something which
作为一名学生、教职员工，或者研究助理什么的，很像经营你自己的生意。作为一名研究助理什么的，很像经营你自己的生意。作为一名学生，你比作为一名员工更能掌控自己的命运。作为一名学生，你可以在三四个月内就从大学退学，对吧？但你知道，除了性骚扰别人之类的，
which is very unlikely, like which would require like you to be a sociopath, like outside of those crazy things, you'll almost never get fired within three to four months. Like, like for you to be fired, for most companies for you to be fired for performance reasons. I mean, you have to actually be it takes like 12 months yeah you have to be messing up for a long time right i mean you really have to be going down the wrong path and know it for a while but school i mean you could you could you know really just like you know especially when you get to the higher levels like a phd um or even worse a professor like if you don't write you know if you don't, you know, if you don't get enough
这非常不可能，这需要你是个反社会者，除了那些疯狂的事情，你几乎永远不会在三四个月内被解雇。对于大多数公司来说，因为表现原因被解雇，你需要……这需要大约 12 个月。是的，你必须在很长一段时间内表现糟糕，对吧？我的意思是，你真的必须走在错误的道路上，并且自己也知道这一点。但在学校，我的意思是，你可以……你知道，特别是当你达到更高的水平，比如博士学位，或者更糟的是教授，如果你不写，你知道，如果你不，你知道，如果你没有获得足够的
grants accepted, and you don't get enough papers accepted, you know, there are people who want, you know, there are conferences that are looking for good papers, but they're also very selective. And if you don't get these things through, then you don't get funding. And then you have to kind of beg your department to float you and that you know ends badly and and um it's so easy to fail just like running your own business and to to just be destroyed in your career um but then on the flip side what you're given in academia is is a lot more freedom like in school you can study whatever you want if you want to be a biologist you'd be a biologist you know you study anything um but you know if you get a job as say a software engineer then then uh obviously it's much more limited right so those are sort of the trade-offs
资助，没有发表足够的论文，你知道，有些人想要，你知道，有些会议在寻找好的论文，但他们也非常挑剔。如果你不能通过这些，你就拿不到资金。然后你不得不求你的系里来维持你，那结果很糟糕。而且，失败太容易了，就像经营自己的生意一样，你的职业生涯会被摧毁。但另一方面，学术界给予你的是更多的自由。在学校，你可以学习任何你想学的东西，如果你想成为一名生物学家，你就是一名生物学家，你知道，你可以学习任何东西。但如果你找到了一份软件工程师的工作，那么显然它就受限得多了，对吧？所以这些就是权衡。
well the other yeah well there's i i guess i think about two other things one is that like in school almost everything was whatever we call greenfield work so like everything is completely unwritten right you're writing stuff from scratch and most of the time when you're working on a job there's already something that exists yeah it might just be requirements but it's it's very rare i mean almost all my time spent coding is working in other people's code working in legacy code you know even when i'm writing new code it has to fit in with other people's code right there is some of that in school but it's you know not as much um and then the other thing is like the continuity of work like you could be working on the same thing so at least in like if you're doing graduate work and research is probably different
嗯，另一个……是的，我想到了另外两件事。一是，在学校里，几乎所有东西都是我们所说的“绿地项目”，也就是一切都是全新的，对吧？你是从零开始写东西。而大多数时候，当你工作时，已经有现成的东西了。是的，可能只是需求，但很少见。我的意思是，我几乎所有写代码的时间都花在处理别人的代码、处理遗留代码上。你知道，即使我在写新代码，它也必须与别人的代码相适应，对吧？学校里也有一些这种情况，但没有那么多。然后另一件事是工作的连续性。你可能在做同一件事，至少如果你在做研究生工作和研究，情况可能不同，
but like an undergraduate you know you're doing little projects but there's typically a long project would last a semester and most times projects are multiple per semester right in a class um and at work like you could easily be working on basically the same thing for years you know but easily you know months and you just every every night you go home and you come back the next morning and you're doing the same thing you were like the night before and you just keep doing it over and over and over again you know yeah right yeah actually there's this uh there's this interesting ted talk and we'll link to it in the show notes but it's about uh what makes us feel good about our work and um the reason why I bring it up is they did this experiment where you, they had a control group where they started off paying them $5 to build this Lego. So they had a box of Lego and you had to build something. I think it was like a robot or something.
但作为本科生，你知道，你在做一些小项目，但通常一个长项目会持续一个学期，而且大多数时候一个学期有多个项目，对吧？在工作中，你可能很容易在几年内基本上都在做同一件事，你知道，很容易，你知道，几个月，你每天晚上回家，第二天早上回来，做的还是你前一天晚上做的事情，你只是不断地重复，重复，再重复，你知道。是的，没错。其实有一个有趣的 TED 演讲，我们会在节目笔记中提供链接，它是关于什么让我们对工作感到满意。我提到它的原因是他们做了这个实验，他们有一个对照组，开始时付给他们 5 美元来拼这个乐高。他们有一盒乐高，你必须拼出某种东西。我想是一个机器人之类的。
And they had the instructions and after you built it they you know put it aside they took it to another room and they gave you a new box and told you build another one but this time it was only for i think it's like four dollars and they had some kind of power function right and so most people like kept building the robots until it was down to like 70 cents um then for the second group of people they had to build the robot and then they destroyed the robot in front of them like disassembled it and had them build it again and that second group like only built the robot once or twice and then said they were done and so like grad school is a little bit like being in that second group because you do a lot of work.
他们有说明书，你拼好之后，他们把它放在一边，带到另一个房间，给你一盒新的，让你再拼一个，但这次报酬我想只有 4 美元，他们有一个幂函数，对吧？所以大多数人一直拼机器人，直到报酬降到 70 美分左右。然后对于第二组人，他们必须拼好机器人，然后他们在他们面前摧毁机器人，拆解它，让他们再拼一次。第二组人只拼了一两次就说他们不干了。所以研究生院有点像第二组，因为你做了很多工作。
A lot of it is alone. And even being a professor, you know, a lot of the work you're really like in your own world. I mean, you have students who are part of your team who kind of report to you, but you're really on your own. And a lot of the work, this is my opinion, so take it with a grain of salt. But a lot of that work kind of gets destroyed you know goes into some research paper and then hopefully someone in industry picks it up and does something with it but i felt like there's a lot of that kind of being in that second group but when you are in industry it's true that like you sometimes can feel like you're a cog in a much larger machine but on the flip side it's like, you're part of a larger machine that's doing something pretty amazing.
很多工作是独自完成的。即使作为一名教授，你知道，很多工作你真的就像在自己的世界里。我的意思是，你有作为团队一部分的学生向你汇报，但你真的是孤军奋战。而且很多工作，这是我的观点，所以仅供参考。但很多工作在某种程度上被摧毁了，你知道，进入了某篇研究论文，然后希望工业界有人能发现它并利用它做点什么。但我感觉有很多那种身处第二组的感觉。但当你身处工业界时，确实有时你会觉得你是一个更大机器中的一颗齿轮，但另一方面，你是更大机器的一部分，正在做一些非常了不起的事情。
And so that's sort of like the big tradeoff I see. All right. On to news. News. So this is pretty topical. There's a database, RethinkDB. And the impression I get is I don't know too much about Rethink, but the impression I get is they're trying to, you know, kind of compete with MongoDB
所以这就是我看到的巨大权衡。好了，进入新闻环节。新闻。这个话题很应景。有一个数据库，RethinkDB。我的印象是，我对 Rethink 了解不多，但我的印象是他们试图，你知道，与 MongoDB 竞争
and some of these other document stores. And they released a new version that has a bunch of cool new features. So if you've never heard of RethinkDB, after you're done listening to this podcast and you are a database expert, you can definitely check it out. Oh, we can offer certifications. You're a certified database expert. Nice. We should team up with Udacity or something.
以及其他一些文档存储。他们发布了一个新版本，有很多很酷的新功能。所以如果你从未听说过 RethinkDB，在你听完这个播客并且你是一位数据库专家之后，你绝对可以去看看。哦，我们可以提供认证。你是一位认证数据库专家。不错。我们应该和 Udacity 之类的机构合作。
Oh, I got that emailed too. You did? Yeah, I was just thinking that. think of that yeah anyone who uh has an audacity account got emailed a couple days ago from sebastian thron himself um saying that they're going to start offering accreditation all right uh this next article is yours as well dhcpio what is that yes dhcp so i used to use DYNDNS, and actually I still use it. And they stopped doing free host names. I didn't know that. Yeah, but I had already kind of been using them for a while, and I got kind of nervous because I have, like,
哦，我也收到了那封邮件。你收到了？是的，我刚才就在想这个。想到那个，是的，任何有 Udacity 账户的人几天前都收到了 Sebastian Thrun 本人发来的邮件，说他们将开始提供认证。好的，下一篇文章也是你的，DHCPIO，那是什么？是的，DHCP。我过去常使用 DYNDNS，实际上我现在还在用。他们停止提供免费主机名了。我不知道。是的，但我已经用了他们一段时间了，我有点紧张，因为我有，比如，
a bunch of things tied to that DNS, scripts, things like that. So I just said, forget it, I'll pay them. I think it was like $20 for the year or something like that. But now I found out about this DHCPIO. I'm going to try it sometime this week. And it looks like it's exactly what DY and DNS used to be, where it's free and you could you set up some kind of service that updates your ip automatically and things like that so i'll check it out i'll report back
一堆东西绑定在那个 DNS 上，脚本之类的。所以我只是说，算了，我付钱给他们。我想一年大约 20 美元左右。但现在我发现了这个 DHCPIO。我这周打算试一下。看起来它正是 DYNDNS 过去的样子，它是免费的，你可以设置某种自动更新 IP 的服务之类的。所以我去看看，我会回来
next show and let you guys know uh if it's if it's solvent or not um but uh at least you know it's good that there's other alternatives out there nice so my next one was a interesting article i was reading it's called folding a fractal so fractals are i think you know for some reason programmers are fascinated by fractals and mathematicians why do you think that is i think because it's just like we don't do at least a lot of programmers i know aren't they don't consider themselves very artistic but it's kind of something where you turn a little knob you change a little equation and you get something kind of beautiful out okay that makes sense it's like computer generated like procedurally generated things right programmers will like build all sorts of i always see procedurally generated you know moonscapes and landscapes and treescapes and people are just like really
下期节目告诉你们它是否好用。但至少，你知道，有其他替代方案是件好事。不错。所以我的下一个是一个有趣的文章，我正在读，叫《折叠分形》。所以分形，我想你知道，出于某种原因，程序员对分形很着迷，数学家也是。你觉得为什么会这样？我想是因为，这就像我们不……至少我认识的很多程序员并不认为自己很有艺术感，但这是一种你转动一个小旋钮，改变一个小方程，就能得到某种美丽的东西。好的，这说得通。这就像计算机生成的，程序生成的，对吧？程序员会构建各种各样的……我总是看到程序生成的月球景观、风景和树木景观，人们只是真的
like a simple algorithm that creates something complex okay conway's game of life right like all these things like you know complexity from simplicity um and this article takes an interesting look which i'd never heard about before for the um i believe it's the julia fractal and and basically talks about the symmetry of it and how you know you always hear the typical thing like you know you a fractal is something that takes place on the complex plane so the vertical axes is the imaginary component and the horizontal axes is the real component i think i'm'm getting that right. And, you know, you take a point there and you apply, you put it into an equation, you get a result, and then you take the result and put it back into the same equation. You keep doing that. And either the results will stay under some limit
像一个简单的算法创造出复杂的东西。康威生命游戏，对吧？所有这些东西，你知道，从简单中产生复杂。这篇文章采取了一个有趣的视角，我以前从未听说过，关于……我相信是 Julia 分形，基本上谈论了它的对称性，以及你知道，你总是听到典型的事情，比如你……分形是在复平面上发生的事情，所以垂直轴是虚部，水平轴是实部，我想我没记错。而且，你知道，你在那里取一个点，应用它，把它放入一个方程，得到一个结果，然后你取结果并把它放回同一个方程。你不断这样做。结果要么保持在某个极限之下，
or will kind of spiral out to an infinite number. And based on that, you kind of make colorings and whether it's in the set or out of the set and uh you know these beautiful things arise and this one you know you typically hear about in this very mathematical description that it's kind of dry kind of boring i guess but it's interesting and this one they talk about it in a way of kind of like folding and transformations and you'll have to read it they have some kind of cool animations they talk about it and it's just a different way of looking at it but you know kind of interesting that even with a different approach you can kind of arrive at the same thing and kind of have a
要么会螺旋式上升到无穷大。基于此，你进行着色，判断它是在集合内还是集合外，你知道，这些美丽的东西就出现了。这个，你知道，你通常在非常数学的描述中听到它，它有点枯燥，有点无聊，我想，但它很有趣。而这个，他们以一种折叠和变换的方式来谈论它，你必须去读一下，他们有一些很酷的动画，他们谈论它，这只是看待它的一种不同方式，但你知道，有点意思，即使使用不同的方法，你也可以得出同样的东西，并有一种
different insight in how and why the shapes arise like they do yeah this is really cool i'm actually on their website now this guy's website is incredible like yeah but it's poor performing well so yeah it's really cool but like i had trouble loading it a couple times yeah so i was just saying how great it is and and all of a sudden i was rotating his website around you actually like move the header of his website around in 3d and then i i got an achievement in the website. I got achievement unlocked for rotating the logo around. But as part of getting that achievement, I broke the website. Like, I can't scroll anymore. Oh, nice.
不同的洞察力，了解形状是如何以及为什么像那样出现的。是的，这真的很酷，我正在看他们的网站。这个人的网站太不可思议了，就像……是的，但它性能很差。所以，是的，它真的很酷，但我加载了几次都有问题。是的，所以我刚才还在说它有多棒，突然我就在 3D 旋转他的网站。你实际上可以移动他网站的标题。我解锁了一个成就，因为旋转了标志。但作为获得该成就的一部分，我把网站弄坏了。比如，我不能滚动了。哦，不错。
But I'm looking at the top of his header. So it is a, I mean, it is an interesting website, but it's not my favorite cup of tea but okay yeah a little too much going on but it's pretty cool i i haven't seen a website like that in a while so you can check out the link in the show notes or just search how to fold a julia fractal yeah definitely so uh yeah i have a piece of news here wave pod music scripting um i have a bunch of friends who are music buffs i uh tried to play the guitar once, and it was embarrassing. And I have no musical talent. Wait, wait, Guitar Hero.
但我正在看他标题的顶部。所以它是一个，我的意思是，它是一个有趣的网站，但不是我最喜欢的类型，但好吧，是的，有点太花哨了，但它很酷。我有一段时间没见过那样的网站了。所以你可以查看节目笔记中的链接，或者直接搜索“如何折叠 Julia 分形”。是的，绝对的。所以，是的，我这里有一条新闻，Wave Pod 音乐脚本。我有一群朋友是音乐迷，我曾经试着弹吉他，那很尴尬。我没有任何音乐天赋。等等，等等，吉他英雄。
I'm great. No, I'm not. I'm mediocre at that game. Well, there you go. That makes me a real musician. I'm also mediocre at Guitar Hero. But this is pretty cool. It's basically all JavaScript, so you can iterate pretty cool. It's basically, it's all JavaScript. So, you know, you can iterate pretty quickly.
我很棒。不，我不是。我在那个游戏里表现平平。好吧，那你就去吧。那让我成为一个真正的音乐家。我在《吉他英雄》里也表现平平。但这很酷。它基本上全是 JavaScript，所以你可以迭代……很酷。它基本上全是 JavaScript。所以，你知道，你可以很快地迭代。
And you just write some scripts. You write, basically they give you a function. And, you know, t comes in where t is, you know, the current time. And what comes out is an amplitude. And they have a few samples where they just do the sine of t, cosine of t, and you can hear the little sine wave mix. And if you do sine of 2t, you can hear a higher frequency sine wave. And then they even have some crazy examples where it's like they've made their own techno, their own electronic music um that you can just like you can just
你只需要写一些脚本。你写，基本上他们给你一个函数。而且，你知道，t 进来了，其中 t 是，你知道，当前时间。输出的是振幅。他们有一些样本，他们只是做 sin(t)，cos(t)，你可以听到小正弦波混合。如果你做 sin(2t)，你可以听到更高频率的正弦波。然后他们甚至有一些疯狂的例子，比如他们制作了自己的电子舞曲，自己的电子音乐，你可以直接……你可以直接
execute in the browser so i thought it was pretty cool i've i've played with something like this before i'm trying to remember the name of it now uh there's like a scripting the same thing but it wasn't it's not like live in an editor uh but it was kind of like a scripting language that you would use and it did something very, very similar to this. Interesting. Yeah, it seems pretty cool. I mean, I know nothing about music theory or anything like that, but this looks really fun. If you're into music and you want to build your own sick techno beats,
在浏览器中执行。所以我认为这很酷。我以前玩过类似的东西，我正在努力回忆它的名字……有类似脚本的东西，同样的事情，但它不是……它不像在编辑器中实时运行，但它是一种你使用的脚本语言，它做的事情非常、非常相似。有趣。是的，看起来很酷。我的意思是，我对音乐理论之类的东西一无所知，但这看起来真的很有趣。如果你喜欢音乐，并且想制作自己疯狂的电子舞曲，
this seems like a really good way to do it. Nice. This kind of goes in line with our last one man we have themed themed news reports this is good yeah totally all right time for book of the show book of the show so uh my book i think you should go first all right i think you should go first no you should go first i think you should go first um let's make should go first. I think you should go first. Let's make this win-win. Let's talk at the same time.
这看起来是一个非常好的方法。不错。这和我们上一个很契合，伙计，我们有主题新闻报道，这很好。是的，完全正确。好了，节目之书时间。节目之书。所以，我的书，我觉得你应该先来。好吧，我觉得你应该先来。不，你应该先来。我觉得你应该先来。嗯，让我们……应该先来。我觉得你应该先来。让我们达成双赢。我们同时说。
Let's make a deal. How about I go first of book of the show, and then you go first tool of the show? Okay. All right. We just had there, ladies and gentlemen, was a negotiation, and I won only because I read Negotiating for Dummies. And I talked about this book a long time ago.
让我们做个交易。我先说节目之书，然后你先说节目工具，怎么样？好的。好吧。女士们先生们，刚才发生了一场谈判，我赢了，仅仅是因为我读了《谈判傻瓜指南》。我很久以前就谈过这本书。
I'm getting ready to buy a car. We've talked about this on the show in the past, but Patrick and I both have pretty new families. Are you getting a minivan? I don't know. So I kind of are you getting a minivan? Uh, I don't know. So, uh, I kind of think the minivan is kind of cool,
我正准备买车。我们过去在节目中谈过这个，但 Patrick 和我都有了相当新的家庭。你要买小型货车吗？我不知道。所以我有点……你要买小型货车吗？呃，我不知道。所以，呃，我有点觉得小型货车挺酷的，
especially because, well, cool isn't the right word, but I like the minivan because it can hold, um, it's sort of like having a hatchback. Like it could hold bicycles on the back and things like that. Um,
特别是，嗯，酷不是合适的词，但我喜欢小型货车，因为它能装，嗯，它有点像掀背车。比如它可以在后面装自行车之类的。嗯，
but then I also see the, like SUV is kind of a nice way to sort of have a bigger car that could hold more people. So do people not like minivans just because they don't think it looks cool? A lot of people really don't like minivans. Yeah, I think the problem is I think minivans got such a bad stigma. It sort of, like, it sort of, like, has the whole soccer mom connotation. Like, I'm completely indebted to my kids' happiness, and my life, like, doesn't mean anything anymore. It's sort of, like, I feel like some people attribute minivans to that, to that idea.
但我同时也看到，SUV 是一种很好的方式，可以拥有一辆更大的车，能装更多人。所以人们不喜欢小型货车只是因为他们觉得它看起来不酷吗？很多人真的不喜欢小型货车。是的，我认为问题在于，我觉得小型货车名声太差了。它有点，它有点，它有那种“足球妈妈”的内涵。比如，我完全为了孩子的幸福而负债，我的生活，比如，不再有任何意义了。我觉得有些人把小型货车归因于那个，那个想法。
And it's obviously not true it's just a car but um you know and then so they came up with this suv where it's like suv i think if i understand correctly it's like a trunk a truck uh chassis so you could feel like you're driving something with muscle but like you know it's like it's like yeah I have a chassis and a frame that can withstand Arctic tundra but I'm gonna drive you know three people you know in suburbia you know so you're relearning how to negotiate so that you don't overpay for your car exactly so you know I'm still in the early stages I'm still trying to figure out what kind of car to get and things like that but I have this book hot on the fingertips for when I get into that. So when you show up to the car dealer, you just plop the book down,
这显然不是真的，它只是一辆车。但，你知道，然后他们发明了 SUV，它就像……SUV，如果我理解正确的话，它就像卡车底盘，所以你可以感觉你在驾驶有肌肉的东西，但，你知道，它就像……是的，我有可以承受北极苔原的底盘和框架，但我要在郊区载三个人，你知道。所以你正在重新学习如何谈判，这样你就不会买车多花钱。没错，所以你知道，我还在早期阶段，我还在试图弄清楚买什么车之类的，但我手头有这本书，准备好应对那个时刻。所以当你出现在车行时，你只是把书往那一放，
and then they're just like, okay, okay, fine. Yeah, that's the plan. The plan is to just start actually just reading quotes from the book until they give me the price I want. But, no, I thought this book was great um you know and so it's uh it's one of the few books that like i actually use as a reference like most of the time you know we actually today's day and age you just look things up online like you know like we we have a lot of books of the show on programming languages and things like that and they great, especially if you don't know the language. Like I'm reading the Swift programming guide right now.
然后他们就像，好吧，好吧，行。是的，这就是计划。计划就是开始实际上只是朗读书中的引语，直到他们给我想要的价格。但是，不，我觉得这本书很棒，嗯，你知道，它是少数几本我真的当作参考书的书，因为大多数时候，你知道，我们现在这个时代，你只是在网上查东西，比如，我们有很多关于编程语言之类的节目之书，它们很棒，特别是如果你不懂这门语言的话。比如我正在读《Swift 编程指南》。
But like then if we do the show. Well, but at the end of the day, if you if you just forget how to use a function or something, you're not going to use that as your reference. You're going to Google it. But this is a book where it's like i feel like to keep going back to it so i figured i would uh go back to it here and make a book of the show which it hasn't been yet so my book of the show is a fiction book called steel heart by brandon sanderson he writes a lot of books this guy's crazy i don't actually know how he writes as many books as he
但如果我们要录节目。好吧，但归根结底，如果你忘记了如何使用一个函数之类的，你不会把它当作参考书。你会去 Google 它。但这是一本我觉得我会不断回看的书，所以我打算在这里回看它，并把它作为节目之书，它之前还没被选过。所以我的节目之书是一本叫《钢铁之心》(Steelheart) 的科幻小说，作者是 Brandon Sanderson。他写了很多书，这家伙疯了，我其实不知道他是怎么写出这么多书的。
does some authors you know it's like a long time between books and he doesn't he actually has multiple series going in this guy but like how do you think they do that like even terry brooks or sorry terry pratchett oh yeah he writes a lot of books yeah how do they do that it's unbelievable and his are his are mostly discworld books but like he does write other books as well yeah but this guy's got like he's got at least like three series going i think like three different universes or whatever maybe more how they do it um and he comes out with like it seems i'd have to go look at his but it seems like every couple months there's a book coming out um yeah i don't know i don't know how people do it
有些作者，你知道，书与书之间间隔很长，而他不是，他实际上有多个系列在进行中。这家伙，但你觉得他们是怎么做到的？即使是 Terry Brooks 或者抱歉，Terry Pratchett，哦，是的，他写了很多书。是的，他们是怎么做到的？这令人难以置信。他的大部分是《碟形世界》系列，但他确实也写其他书。是的，但这家伙至少有三个系列在进行中，我想，三个不同的宇宙什么的，也许更多。他们是怎么做到的？嗯，他出来，就像……我得去看看他的，但看起来每隔几个月就有一本书出来。是的，我不知道，我不知道人们是怎么做到的。
and some people it's like you know i'm reading a trilogy and it's like been like two or three years since the last book came out it's like i really want the next one the author's saying like it's going to be like another year at least and it's like ah yeah um so sometimes it's better just to wait till the trilogy is done and then start reading it yeah the lady who wrote the vampire books uh What's it called? The one with the vampires and the werewolves? Anne Rice? Like, Interview with a Vampire?
有些人，就像，你知道，我正在读一个三部曲，距离上一本书出版已经两三年了，就像我真的很想要下一本，作者说，就像至少还要一年，就像啊。是的，嗯，所以有时等到三部曲写完再开始读会更好。写吸血鬼书的那位女士，呃，叫什么来着？那个有吸血鬼和狼人的？Anne Rice？比如《夜访吸血鬼》？
No, no, the one that they made the movies of. You know, the girl, like, she has a vampire and a werewolf, and she doesn't know which one to date. Oh, Twilight. Twilight, that's right. So the lady who wrote Twilightilight apparently she was going to write i guess like another like some kind of epilogue um book but then the book got leaked out and so she canceled it and that kind of blew my mind because it's not like you know it's not like
不，不，拍成电影的那部。你知道，那个女孩，比如，她有一个吸血鬼和一个狼人，她不知道该和谁约会。哦，《暮光之城》。《暮光之城》，没错。所以写《暮光之城》的那位女士，显然她打算写，我想，另一本某种尾声书，但后来书泄露了，所以她取消了。这让我很震惊，因为这不像，你知道，这不像
you can't cancel a book i mean it takes so long it just i thought that was pretty wild it takes so long and it's such an individual effort that like the idea that even if someone spoiled my book that i would just throw away a year of my life yeah but you wouldn't write that kind of book nobody's gonna spoil your programming book, my friend. I'm just saying, like, no matter what book I wrote, if somebody spoiled it. In the end, it compiles. If somebody spoiled anything that I spent a year working on, I would still just finish it. But, you know, then again, she's already written so many books, it probably doesn't matter. Yeah.
你不能取消一本书，我的意思是，它花的时间太长了。我只是觉得那太疯狂了。它花的时间太长了，而且是个人的努力，以至于即使有人剧透了我的书，我也会扔掉我一年的生活。是的，但你不会写那种书。没人会剧透你的编程书，我的朋友。我只是说，无论我写什么书，如果有人剧透了它。最后，它编译通过了。如果有人剧透了我花了一年时间做的任何事情，我仍然会把它完成。但是，话又说回来，她已经写了那么多书，可能没关系了。是的。
Some people at that point, like, it's probably not for the money anymore, right? Yeah, I guess if someone spoils it, there's nothing left happened with the jk rowling right the person who wrote harry potter wrote another book oh man i wasn't prepared for this but she wrote another book but she wrote it under a pen name and i think it kind of got like like it was well reviewed but not like people like didn't get excited it wasn't like a bestseller i'm probably butchering this story and then like kind of came out that she wrote someone leaked like her publisher or something leaked that it was her and then all of a sudden it was like you know through the roof sales and all of a sudden it was the you know great book and all this stuff oh wow you know but like she was trying to dodge
有些人到了那个地步，就像，可能不再是为了钱了，对吧？是的，我想如果有人剧透了，就没什么剩下的了。JK Rowling 发生过这种情况，对吧？写《哈利·波特》的那个人写了另一本书。哦，天哪，我没准备好这个。但她写了另一本书，但她用笔名写的，我想它有点像……就像它评价很好，但不是像人们……没有感到兴奋，它不是畅销书。我可能把这个故事搞砸了。然后就像传出来她写的，有人泄露了，比如她的出版商什么的泄露了那是她，然后突然之间，就像，你知道，销量爆棚，突然之间它就是，你知道，伟大的书，所有这些东西。哦，哇。你知道，但她试图躲避
it you know because she didn't need the money so she just probably just wanted to write and not have people view it in the light of harry potter yeah it's interesting there was some writer who gave a ted talk recently uh who um it was one of these like i think the the topic was like how do you survive your own success or something like that and basically uh she just said that like she had like huge writer's block because she was like consumed with like her own success like not that she was like she was gloating over herself every day but but it was more just like she felt like how can she top that you know and the the short story is that she just decided to write a book like she kind of just got the cojones to write the book and the second book tanked everyone was like this is
它，你知道，因为她不需要钱，所以她可能只是想写，而不让人们在《哈利·波特》的光环下看待它。是的，这很有趣。最近有个作家做了一个 TED 演讲，呃，谁……它是那种，我想主题是“你如何从自己的成功中幸存”之类的，基本上，她只是说她有巨大的写作障碍，因为她被自己的成功所消耗，不是说她每天都在炫耀自己，而是更多地觉得她怎么能超越那个，你知道。简短的故事是，她决定写一本书，她有点鼓起勇气写了那本书，第二本书失败了，每个人都说这
nothing like the first book um and then that sort of like gave her the freedom to write the third book which ended up being like her best book or something but i uh yeah apparently like uh you know again like i was saying it's such an individual effort that like it's sort of like movies you know i would imagine like at some point you're going to the movie just to see ge Clooney, and it doesn't really matter what he does. It's just kind of a weird dynamic. Coming full circle, Steelheart by Brandon Sanderson. And this is kind of like an interesting take on the comic book superhero,
和第一本书完全不同。然后这给了她写第三本书的自由，那本书最终成了她最好的书什么的。但我……是的，显然，就像我说的，这是一种个人的努力，就像电影一样，你知道，我想象在某个时刻，你去看电影只是为了看乔治·克鲁尼，他做什么其实并不重要。这只是一种奇怪的动态。回到原点，《钢铁之心》，作者 Brandon Sanderson。这有点像对漫画书超级英雄、
supervillain theme. Oh, okay. So it's kind of that way, but it's not a Marvel universe. It's not like DC Universe. And it's a book that way but not like it's not a marvel universe it's not like dc universe and it's a book not a comic book um but kind of in that kind of theme but with some interesting twists on it so it was nice it was a good read it's a short rather short book okay so it's not a comic book it's uh no but it's like in that kind of world right like same kind of ideas cool cool cool so i get to go first for tool of the show.
超级反派主题的有趣解读。哦，好的。所以它是那种方式，但它不是漫威宇宙。它不是 DC 宇宙。而且它是一本书，那种方式，但不是像……它不是漫威宇宙，它不是 DC 宇宙，而且它是一本书，不是漫画书。嗯，但有点那种主题，但有一些有趣的转折。所以它很好，这是一本好书，这是一本相当短的书。好的，所以它不是漫画书，它是……不，但它是在那种世界里，对吧？就像同样的想法。酷，酷，酷。所以我先来介绍节目工具。
All right. Mine is Arduino. So we've talked about Arduinos before, and I recently used it for a project, and people at work were giving me a hard time because, you know, everybody's like, oh, Arduino's overpriced, and, you know, you can get this other ARM device,
好的。我的是 Arduino。所以我们之前谈过 Arduino，我最近在一个项目里用了它，同事们给我找麻烦，因为，你知道，每个人都说，哦，Arduino 太贵了，而且，你知道，你可以买到这个其他的 ARM 设备，
which is 32-bit and 100 megahertz and only $5. And then by the time they finished that discussion, I actually had the project done on my Arduino. And I'm not like Arduino is the best thing ever. A lot of people try to do stuff with it that you should just move to another processor. But if you're trying to do rapid prototyping, I've realized how wonderful of a tool it is because there's so much example code in libraries and peripherals out there that just work with it and you just do it and it works and if you need to it's same thing
它是 32 位的，100 兆赫兹，只要 5 美元。然后当他们讨论完时，我已经用我的 Arduino 完成了项目。我不是说 Arduino 是最好的东西。很多人试图用它做一些你应该换到另一个处理器去做的事情。但如果你在做快速原型设计，我意识到它是一个多么美妙的工具，因为有太多的示例代码、库和外设，它们直接就能用，你只需要做，它就能工作。如果你需要，它是一样的
with kind of linux distributions in a way it's nice if there's a big community because somebody probably asked a question so it's good if you can ask a question and eventually someone answers it it's better if you just look for the question and it's already been asked and answered with arduino don't you have to write in some wacky language though yeah but it's basically just c like i just write in c and it works oh really okay sort of i mean i don't know i don't do any like applications programming in it right so it's all like manipulate some hardware is what i'm typically doing with it and so i'm normally grabbing some library and some example code and changing it just enough
某种程度上和 Linux 发行版一样，如果有一个庞大的社区是很好的，因为有人可能问过问题，所以如果你能问一个问题，最终有人回答它是好的。如果你只是寻找问题，它已经被问过并回答了，那就更好了。用 Arduino，你不是必须用某种古怪的语言写吗？是的，但它基本上就是 C，我只是用 C 写，它就能工作。哦，真的吗？好的。某种程度上，我的意思是，我不知道，我不在里面做任何应用程序编程，对吧？所以它全是，比如操纵一些硬件，这是我通常用它做的。所以我通常抓取一些库和一些示例代码，稍微修改一下，
to where it works and uh it's really fast for that and you know i install the ide i do the thing and it's not i couldn't imagine trying to do a complicated project in it it would probably be terrible but like i said in the time that i could have figured out how to get a compiler installed properly compiling and properly flashing and you know the bootloader working on a five dollar whatever other arm board um it probably would have been very very powerful and would have taken me weeks to like get working before i started and i was done and you know like a couple hours for the thing i was trying to do yeah the arduino has wi-fi right uh some versions of it do yeah yeah because as long as it has wi-fi you could do almost everything on a desktop at least you know if you're prototyping you don't really need to have that much logic on the i'm not sure i'm not sure where you're going
直到它能工作。而且，它在这方面真的很快。而且，你知道，我安装 IDE，我做这件事，它不是……我无法想象试图在里面做一个复杂的项目，那可能会很糟糕。但就像我说的，在我能弄清楚如何正确安装编译器、正确编译、正确刷写，你知道，引导加载程序在五美元的什么其他 ARM 板上工作的时间里……它可能非常、非常强大，但我开始之前可能需要几周时间才能让它工作，而我已经完成了。而且，你知道，我试图做的事情只用了几个小时。是的，Arduino 有 Wi-Fi，对吧？呃，有些版本有。是的，是的，因为只要它有 Wi-Fi，你几乎可以在桌面上做所有事情，至少，你知道，如果你在做原型设计，你真的不需要在……我不确定，我不确定你要去哪里
but yes well no i was saying like like well because, you know, if you could do everything on the desktop and just communicate with Arduino devices, then the ID doesn't really matter that much, right? Yeah, so I mean, that's one way to look at it, right? Like some people, even some of the Arduinos have this where they can pretend to be basically a keyboard, right? And so there's interesting like data logger Arduino stuff where you just want to like measure the temperature in your office, right? could try to go buy some usb thermometer and figure out some sdk
但是的，好吧，不，我是说，比如，因为，你知道，如果你能在桌面上做所有事情，只需与 Arduino 设备通信，那么 IDE 其实没那么重要，对吧？是的，所以我的意思是，这是一种看待它的方式，对吧？比如有些人，甚至一些 Arduino 也有这个功能，它们可以假装基本上是一个键盘，对吧？所以有一些有趣的数据记录 Arduino 的东西，你只是想测量办公室的温度，对吧？可以尝试去买一些 USB 温度计，弄清楚一些 SDK。
or you can like hook an arduino up to it and have it type in the numbers into a spreadsheet and push enter after the end of each reading um it's just kind of an interesting hack um but in some ways is really straightforward and quick. So if it works, it works. And if you need to go to something more complicated, you can, and you'll know sooner. So, and that's why Arduino is my tool of the show, even for, I don't consider myself an expert programmer, but someone who does a lot of embedded work. Like if I had a board that was my preferred setup and I went to it all the time, sure, maybe that would be better. But since I don't, I, you know, when I have to do stuff with hardware and I just need
或者你可以像把Arduino连接到它上面，让它把数字输入到电子表格中，并在每次读数结束时按下回车键。嗯，这算是一种有趣的黑客手段，但在某些方面确实非常直接和快捷。所以如果它管用，那就行了。如果你需要更复杂的东西，你也可以随时切换，而且你会更早地发现这一点。所以，这就是为什么Arduino是我的节目工具，即使对于——我不认为自己是专家级程序员，但我是一个做很多嵌入式工作的人。比如，如果我有一个首选的板子设置，并且我一直都在用它，当然，也许那样会更好。但既然我没有，我，你知道，当我必须处理硬件方面的事情，而我只需要
it done, um, Arduino. Yeah. Cool. So what's your most recent like home project, um, with Arduino? With Arduino? So, uh, I, it's kind of hard to explain i'll do the other one so i was trying to i wanted to to build like something for like just like entertainment value to um move like a flag back and forth you can kind of think so i want to just like attach a servo motor to a flag and like
把它搞定，嗯，Arduino。是的。酷。那么你最近用Arduino做的家庭项目是什么？用Arduino？所以，呃，我，这有点难解释，我会做另一个，所以我当时试图，我想建造一些东西，仅仅是为了娱乐价值，嗯，让一面旗帜来回摆动，你可以这样想，所以我想把一个伺服电机连接到旗帜上，然后像
have it wave the flag right okay um you know very patriotic i don't want to have to actually wave the flag so i built something to wave the flag for me so in preparation for july 4th you're gonna have a robotic yeah waiver so it's basically that yeah and so i programmed arduino and just told it to go from one extreme to the other back and forth back and forth back and forth and it was done in like i already had a servo i I had an Arduino board, hacked it together and it was done. Before that, I built an Arduino that moved two stepper motors that were on pulleys for strings. And they were attached to a pen and they moved the pen around a piece of paper and drew pictures. What? That sounds amazing.
让它挥动旗帜，对吧，好的，嗯，你知道，非常爱国，我不想真的去挥动旗帜，所以我造了一些东西来帮我挥动旗帜。所以为了准备7月4日，你打算有一个机器人，是的，挥旗手，所以基本上就是那样，是的，所以我编程了Arduino，只是告诉它从一个极端到另一个极端来回摆动，来回摆动，来回摆动，它很快就完成了，就像我已经有一个伺服电机，我有一个Arduino板，把它拼凑在一起，它就完成了。在那之前，我做了一个Arduino，移动了两个连接在滑轮绳子上的步进电机。它们连接到一支笔上，它们在纸上移动笔并画图。什么？听起来太棒了。
Oh, well, it was kind of the hardware part was interesting. And then like it was just programming after that. It was like, oh, this is kind of the hardware part was interesting and then like it was just programming after that it was like oh this is kind of boring actually so you you uh you could give it like uh so you give it like an image and then there's already tools like people have done this before which i guess is why it wasn't that interesting to me because it kind of felt cheap um but like people you encode it threshold or whatever and then you do like traveling salesman problem like how do you go from all the the point cloud basically to form like a pattern that looks like the image right and then you send those coordinates for each of the paths um and the arduino would move the pen to that move it move it move it and you just keep streaming the commands over
哦，好吧，硬件部分很有趣。然后就像之后只是编程一样。就像，哦，这有点——硬件部分很有趣，然后就像之后只是编程一样，就像，哦，这其实有点无聊。所以你，呃，你可以给它，呃，所以你给它一张图像，然后已经有工具了，人们以前做过这个，我想这就是为什么它对我来说没那么有趣，因为它感觉有点廉价，嗯，但是像人们你编码它，阈值处理或者其他什么，然后你做像旅行商问题，就像你如何从所有的点云基本上形成一个看起来像图像的图案，对吧，然后你为每个路径发送那些坐标，嗯，Arduino会把笔移动到那个位置，移动它，移动它，移动它，你只需要不断地流式传输命令
that sounds awesome man you should document these i mean i would love to see a video of that working yeah but like i said it was something other people had already done so i was like i was just following their instructions i wasn't really adding anything new patrick we don't know those people we know you okay okay yes i i'm terrible i don't contribute back to the internet i hoard it all the way in my head okay that's pretty awesome my tool this show is not definitely not as cool but uh i was actually talking to a co-worker about sort of productivity tools um i have a bunch of like you know at work i have a bunch of email add-ons and all sorts of email hacks to do all sorts of crazy so i like this naive base filter
听起来太棒了，伙计，你应该记录下这些，我的意思是，我很想看到一个视频展示它是如何工作的。是的，但就像我说的，这是别人已经做过的事情，所以我当时想，我只是在遵循他们的指示，我并没有真正添加任何新的东西。帕特里克，我们不认识那些人，我们认识你。好吧，好吧，是的，我很糟糕，我不向互联网贡献任何东西，我把它全部囤积在我的脑子里。好吧，那太棒了。我这个节目的工具绝对没有那么酷，但呃，我实际上正在和一位同事谈论某种生产力工具，嗯，我有一堆，你知道，在工作中我有一堆电子邮件插件和各种各样的电子邮件黑客技巧来做各种疯狂的事情，所以我喜欢这个朴素贝叶斯过滤器
that runs on my email and um just to like you know it can actually shave hours off your workday like if you can get your productivity up uh like or at least by up i mean like more efficient wait it doesn't shave hours off your workday you just get more done in a workday uh yeah i guess that's unless you're like i don't know most people you kind of expected to work a certain amount right so like if you get done sooner do you just go home um i typically end up doing more like well so so i've never you know left at 1 p.m or something like that right but at the same time i don don't really follow any schedule. I just kind of have this feeling like, okay, now it's time to go.
它在我的电子邮件上运行，嗯，只是为了，你知道，它实际上可以从你的工作日中节省几个小时，就像如果你能提高你的生产力，嗯，或者至少通过提高，我的意思是更有效率。等等，它不会从你的工作日中节省几个小时，你只是在工作日中完成了更多的工作。嗯，是的，我想那是，除非你像，我不知道，大多数人，你被期望工作一定的时间，对吧？所以如果你早点做完，你是直接回家吗？我通常最终会做更多的事情，嗯，所以，所以我从来没有在下午1点左右离开过，或者类似的事情，对吧？但与此同时，我并没有真正遵循任何时间表。我只是有一种感觉，好吧，现在是时候走了。
So instead of working later, you can go home at a good time and still have gotten done a good work day's worth of work. Yeah, right. So this tool is called NV-Alt. There was originally a tool called Notational Velocity. I think the tool still exists. It's for OS X. It's pretty cool. It uses this wiki format.
所以与其工作到很晚，你可以在一个好的时间回家，并且仍然完成了一天的工作量。是的，没错。所以这个工具叫NV-Alt。最初有一个工具叫Notational Velocity。我想这个工具仍然存在。它是为OS X准备的。它很酷。它使用这种维基格式。
So basically, you write in this wiki format, and it has this pane off to the right that has the rendered format that's updated in real time. And the cool thing about it is it just feels very natural. You write what you want the note to be. Then you hit enter and you start writing the note. And it has a search functionality. It has a bunch of cool stuff.
所以基本上，你用这种维基格式书写，它在右侧有一个窗格，实时更新渲染后的格式。最酷的事情是它感觉非常自然。你写下你想要的笔记内容。然后你按回车键，就开始写笔记了。它有搜索功能。它有很多很酷的东西。
The thing is I don't really like the wiki format. I much prefer Markdown, especially the GitHub-flavored Markdown. The extended Markdown has tables and things like that. And so NV-Alt is an open-source alternative to notational velocity, which uses a markdown instead of wiki markup. So I used that. I found out, you know, because we were doing this show, I did some research, and there's actually one called NVPy,
问题是我不太喜欢维基格式。我更喜欢Markdown，尤其是GitHub风格的Markdown。扩展的Markdown有表格之类的东西。所以NV-Alt是Notational Velocity的一个开源替代品，它使用Markdown而不是维基标记。所以我用了那个。我发现，你知道，因为我们在做这个节目，我做了一些研究，实际上有一个叫NVPy的，
which also supports Markdown, and it's written in Python, so it works on any OS. So you can actually take notes on Linux, those notes will magically work on OSX or on Windows or what have you. Also, it has sort of this, it can be locked with a password. So in other words, you can put all your notes on, say, like Dropbox or Google Drive or iCloud or what have you, and share them among your computers and not have to worry about somebody who doesn't know the password getting access to your notes. So it's got pretty good security there.
它也支持Markdown，而且是用Python编写的，所以它可以在任何操作系统上运行。所以你实际上可以在Linux上做笔记，这些笔记会神奇地在OSX或Windows或其他什么系统上工作。此外，它还有一种，它可以被密码锁定。所以换句话说，你可以把你所有的笔记放在，比如，Dropbox或Google Drive或iCloud或其他什么地方，并在你的电脑之间共享它们，而不必担心不知道密码的人访问你的笔记。所以它有相当不错的安全性。
It has the indexing and all that. Oh, also you can at any point turn your notes into sort of like a wiki thing. So it'll basically take all of your notes, render the HTML, and then put them in file names based on the title and cradle index. So it's sort of like your own personal wiki that you could publish to the Internet. I've never used that feature, but I just think it's kind of cool. Like one of these days I might need that. Um, but, uh, but yeah, so envy all it's it's, if you need to kind of take notes, whether you're a student or, you know, during meetings or something like that, I found that one really useful. Interesting. I don't have to check that. I don't have a good note taking app, but I
它有索引和所有这些。哦，你还可以随时把你的笔记变成某种维基之类的东西。所以它基本上会把你所有的笔记拿出来，渲染成HTML，然后根据标题和索引把它们放在文件名中。所以它有点像你自己的个人维基，你可以发布到互联网上。我从来没用过那个功能，但我只是觉得它很酷。就像有一天我可能需要它。嗯，但是，呃，但是是的，所以NV-Alt，如果你需要做笔记，无论你是学生，还是，你知道，在会议期间或类似的事情，我发现那个非常有用。有趣。我不必检查那个。我没有一个好的笔记应用程序，但我
do take lots of notes. Typically I used to use this emacs extension I forgot what it was called but yeah this is way better than that this is similar to one I've considered before to do dot txt oh okay I haven't seen that one yeah yeah
确实做了很多笔记。通常我过去使用这个Emacs扩展，我忘了它叫什么了，但是的，这比那个好多了，这类似于我之前考虑过的一个，todo.txt。哦，好的，我没见过那个。是的，是的。
maybe I'll come back with that as a tool to show if I try it alright yeah let me know try this one and try that I haven't heard of try it. All right, yeah, let me know. Try this one and try the... I haven't heard of that one, so if that one's better, let me know. Okay, so on to databases. Data, big data. We're going to store this away and update the row containing this podcast file. No.
也许我会回来把它作为一个节目工具，如果我试用一下的话。好的，是的，让我知道。试用这个，试用那个，我没听说过试用它。好的，是的，让我知道。试用这个，试用那个……我没听说过那个，所以如果那个更好，让我知道。好的，那么进入数据库。数据，大数据。我们要把这个存起来，并更新包含这个播客文件的行。不。
Yeah, the SQL syntax, for some reason, I could use it every day. There are some times where, let's say over the course of a month, I use SQL every day, and I still don't remember the syntax. I just don't know why. I remember there's select star in table or from table. See, there you go. Anyways, so before there were databases, which is probably going way back because databases have been around for a long time. Actually, how long?
是的，SQL语法，出于某种原因，我可以每天使用它。有些时候，比如说在一个月的时间里，我每天都使用SQL，但我仍然记不住语法。我就是不知道为什么。我记得有select star in table或者from table。你看，这不就有了吗。总之，在数据库出现之前，这可能要追溯到很久以前，因为数据库已经存在很长时间了。实际上，有多久？
Databases were around in the 1960s so before that and up to today even people use flat files right i mean it makes sense like you just have uh you know if you have some file on your computer um you can actually do uh you can actually seek in that file like most files are random access files um as long as you're not using like a tape or something like that and so you can actually just seek to any point in the file and read that point or write that point and so a lot of people will just write out like you know text files like for example if you have a web server every time somebody visits your website you might append a line to some flat file or raw text file saying who came to your website.
数据库在20世纪60年代就出现了，所以在那之前，直到今天，人们甚至还在使用平面文件，对吧？我的意思是这很有道理，就像你只是有，呃，你知道，如果你的电脑上有一些文件，嗯，你实际上可以，呃，你实际上可以在那个文件中寻找，就像大多数文件是随机访问文件一样，只要你不是在使用磁带之类的东西，所以你实际上可以只是寻找文件中的任何点并读取该点或写入该点，所以很多人只是写出像，你知道，文本文件，例如，如果你有一个网络服务器，每次有人访问你的网站，你可能会在某个平面文件或原始文本文件中追加一行，说明谁访问了你的网站。
And, you know, this is great for a lot of things. But it doesn't do everything. There's a lot of reasons to use a database. You know, one of them is indexing. So the idea here is you have a lot of data in your database. Let's say you have a list of names. So you have Patrick, you have Jason, you have Jennifer, Sophia, you have all these names, you know, a column just full of different people's names. So you know most of the time you want to look
而且，你知道，这对很多事情来说都很棒。但它不能做所有事情。使用数据库有很多原因。你知道，其中之一是索引。所以这里的想法是你的数据库中有很多数据。假设你有一个名字列表。所以你有帕特里克，你有杰森，你有詹妮弗，索菲亚，你有所有这些名字，你知道，一列全是不同人的名字。所以你知道大多数时候你想查找
someone up by their name, like, give me all the Patricks or give me all the Jasons. So what you don't want is to have to look through every name in your whole database and then pull out the Patricks as you see them. Like, you'd want to do some kind of pre-processing and build an index such that when you say, like, give me all the Patrick's, it's kind of ready to go. What's the difference between an index and a reverse index? Do you know? Nope. Don't know. I don't know.
某人的名字，比如，给我所有的帕特里克或者给我所有的杰森。所以你不想做的是必须查看整个数据库中的每个名字，然后在看到它们时把帕特里克挑出来。就像，你会想要做某种预处理并建立一个索引，这样当你像说，给我所有的帕特里克时，它就准备好了。索引和反向索引有什么区别？你知道吗？不。不知道。我不知道。
I think, so, you know, a reverse index is where, I think it works like this. I think, works like this. I think, let's say you have a bunch of records. An index says, OK, record 1 has Patrick in it. So if I look for record number 1, I want to get Patrick. Or if I look for record number 14,500, that one's Jason. That's an index.
我想，所以，你知道，反向索引是，我想它是这样工作的。我想，它是这样工作的。我想，假设你有一堆记录。索引说，好的，记录1里有帕特里克。所以如果我查找记录1，我想得到帕特里克。或者如果我查找记录14500，那个是杰森。这就是索引。
Like you're indexing into the database. A reverse index is when you want to go the other way, like give me all the Jasons or all the Patricks. So, you know, even a flat file could have indexing because you could just say like every 10 megabytes in the file is a new person. Yeah, so it's just reversed versus forward it's just like a matter of how the data is stored versus how it's looked up kind of right so yeah like you said like if you have a log right you first you just start adding lines to the end of the
就像你在索引数据库一样。反向索引是当你想要反过来做的时候，比如给我所有的杰森或所有的帕特里克。所以，你知道，即使是平面文件也可以有索引，因为你可以说，比如文件中每10兆字节是一个新人。是的，所以它只是反向与正向，这只是数据如何存储与如何查找的问题，对吧？所以是的，就像你说的，如果你有一个日志，对吧，你首先只是开始在日志的末尾添加行，
log but eventually you want to like have a way to go straight to a given day when it gets really really big right and you don't want to have to parse all the days to find out like where a given day starts so you may like put up at the top like day one is that bite this day two is that bite this day three is that bite this right it's like a ford index because kind of like the way it's stored reverse index would be like if some for some reason you wanted to go like the other way like from a given entry to like know what day it was in right like right right so it's not exactly the way it was stored um you know that data in this case is kind of a bad example because it's probably stored in that portion of the log but if it wasn't like hey i'm at some part of a file for some
但最终你想要有一种方法可以直接跳转到某一天，当它变得非常非常大时，对吧？而且你不想必须解析所有的日子来找出某一天从哪里开始，所以你可能会在顶部放上，比如第一天是那个字节，第二天是那个字节，第三天是那个字节，对吧？这就像一个正向索引，因为有点像它的存储方式。反向索引就像如果出于某种原因你想反过来做，比如从一个给定的条目到知道它是在哪一天，对吧？对，对，所以它不完全是它的存储方式，嗯，你知道，这种情况下的数据是一个糟糕的例子，因为它可能存储在日志的那部分，但如果它不是，比如嘿，我在文件的某个部分，出于某种
reason i want to go back to like how what day it was that you know like going the other way yeah exactly or like tell me what days user x logged in or something like that yeah and you need to reverse it next so the point is databases do both of these so um so you don't have to think about how to build it's actually very hard building those structures um so you don't have to think about that the database will do that for you similarly to what the discussion is as it typically comes as data grows right so like it starts off simple you do something simple that's fine then as it grows you start having a problem like caching so if the file gets really big and you're accessing it in the same way a lot if this is a flat file you know depending on your
原因我想回到它是什么日子，你知道，就像反过来做，是的，完全正确，或者像告诉我用户X在哪些日子登录了，或者类似的事情，是的，你需要反向索引。所以重点是数据库两者都做，所以，嗯，所以你不必考虑如何构建，构建这些结构实际上非常困难，所以你不必考虑那个，数据库会为你做。类似于讨论的内容，它通常随着数据的增长而出现，对吧？所以它开始很简单，你做一些简单的事情，那很好，然后随着它的增长，你开始遇到像缓存这样的问题，所以如果文件变得非常大，并且你以同样的方式频繁访问它，如果这是一个平面文件，你知道，取决于你的
ram and your cache maybe it's getting caching at like the cpu level but as it grows like bigger and bigger right like you want a more sophisticated caching scheme that understands the access patterns you're likely to have yeah exactly yeah i mean the the cpu will cache in its own like you know l1 and l2 cache but these are very small right but the uh you know a database can you know cache like 200 megabytes of information you know in main memory and it does like the caching between like your hard drive and the main memory and uh and again the way that most databases do the caching is very sophisticated so i know you don't want to be writing that yourself yeah no it grows like you could write simple caching yourself but yeah more complicated it's better for someone else to
内存和你的缓存，也许它在CPU级别得到了缓存，但随着它变得越来越大，对吧，你想要一个更复杂的缓存方案，了解你可能有的访问模式。是的，完全正确，是的，我的意思是CPU会在它自己的，你知道，L1和L2缓存中缓存，但这些非常小，对吧？但呃，你知道，数据库可以，你知道，在主内存中缓存200兆字节的信息，你知道，它在你的硬盘和主内存之间做缓存，而且，再次，大多数数据库做缓存的方式非常复杂，所以我知道你不想自己写那个。是的，不，它会增长，你可以自己写简单的缓存，但是的，更复杂的话，最好让别人来
have done it yeah definitely um another one is redundancy so you know you want uh you want all your data to be backed up in real time. Like imagine if you're processing orders, like you're a furniture, online furniture store or something. You know, if your computer dies or even if, you know, just the power goes out and you have to,
做这件事，是的，绝对，嗯，另一个是冗余，所以你知道，你想要你所有的数据实时备份。就像想象一下如果你正在处理订单，就像你是一家家具，在线家具店或类似的东西。你知道，如果你的电脑死机了，或者即使，你知道，只是电源断了，你必须，
your computer hard resets, you know, if somebody is in the middle of an order and you double charge them or you forget to charge them or something, it could be a big deal, right? Or if you uh if you lose the entire your your all of your data and you have no way to recover um that's a huge disaster right and then it gets really tricky because the way you back things up i mean you could have infinite loops like you'd have a student record who which points to the classroom they have a student record which points to the
你的电脑强制重启，你知道，如果有人在订单处理过程中，你重复收费或者你忘记收费或者类似的事情，那可能是一个大问题，对吧？或者如果你，呃，如果你丢失了全部的，你的，你所有的数据，并且你没有任何方法恢复，那是一个巨大的灾难，对吧？然后它变得非常棘手，因为你备份东西的方式，我的意思是你可以有无限循环，就像你有一个学生记录，它指向他们所在的教室，你有一个学生记录，它指向他们所在的
classroom they're in, and the classroom points to the students that are in that class. So you can have these sort of circular references and things like that. And so being able to back up something like that, some kind of structured data, and to recover it, these things are really tricky. And you don't want to be implementing them yourself
教室，而教室指向在该班级的学生。所以你可以有这些循环引用之类的东西。所以能够备份像那样的一些结构化数据，并恢复它，这些事情真的非常棘手。而且你不想自己实现它们。
similarly trying to scale them so running on one computer is all well and good more memory more cpu eventually that runs out and now you have to scale to multiple computers also called distributed databases right and now you have a whole host of other problems you got to handle about do you put one table on one computer and another table on another computer or some users can data on one computer and some on another? And then how do you split up that? Right. And like starts to play in like a lot of different choices about how you want to scale the data and, you know, understanding the problem set so that you know that you're scaling in a way that's going to be beneficial for you yeah exactly yeah i mean most of these databases if you go to amazon or microsoft or google or any of these like big services i mean there's just there's a ton of computers that are
同样试图扩展它们，所以在一台电脑上运行很好，更多的内存，更多的CPU，最终它会耗尽，现在你必须扩展到多台电脑，也称为分布式数据库，对吧？现在你有一大堆其他问题需要处理，关于你把一个表放在一台电脑上，另一个表放在另一台电脑上，还是有些用户的数据在一台电脑上，有些在另一台？然后你如何拆分那个？对。而且开始涉及到很多关于你如何扩展数据的不同选择，而且，你知道，理解问题集，这样你就知道你的扩展方式对你是有益的。是的，完全正确，是的，我的意思是大多数这些数据库，如果你去亚马逊或微软或谷歌或任何这些大服务，我的意思是那里有大量的电脑，它们
all working together to store like one collection of information and yeah trying to implement that again really hard very hard to get right even the experts don't get it right all the time right there's a lot of heuristics a lot of guessing and hoping that certain conditions aren't met and things like that and there's a lot of fingers that are crossed and and uh um and so it's definitely not like a solved problem and you don't want to be in the business of trying to solve it i mean unless unless you're getting a phd or something in databases but for the rest of us you know we should leave it to the experts um also segmentation right i mean most people access access data in certain patterns, and they might only need, you know, if you're looking at, say, like SQL, which we'll talk about later, row of data is kind of one atomic thing,
都在一起工作来存储像一个信息集合，而且是的，试图实现那个，再次，非常困难，很难做到正确，即使是专家也不能一直做到正确，对吧？有很多启发式方法，很多猜测，并希望某些条件不被满足，诸如此类的事情，而且有很多手指交叉，而且，嗯，所以它绝对不像是一个已解决的问题，你不想进入试图解决它的业务，我的意思是除非，除非你正在攻读博士学位或数据库方面的什么东西，但对于我们其他人，你知道，我们应该把它留给专家，还有分段，对吧？我的意思是大多数人以特定的模式访问数据，他们可能只需要，你知道，如果你看，比如SQL，我们稍后会谈到，数据行是一种原子性的东西，
I'm going to break it up into pieces. Or as Patrick said earlier, I'm going to break each day and put each day in a different place. And it can look at sort of your access patterns and also some hints that you can give the database. And it can divide your data, segment your data into different pieces, such that it doesn't have to do a lot of extra reading. It can just read the parts that you want and do that very efficiently. I guess it should be pointed out some of this we're blurring a little bit, maybe it doesn't matter, between database and a database management system.
我要把它拆成碎片。或者正如帕特里克刚才所说，我要拆分每一天，把每一天放在不同的地方。它可以查看你的访问模式以及你可以给数据库的一些提示。它可以划分你的数据，将你的数据分段成不同的部分，这样它就不必做大量的额外读取。它只需要读取你想要的部分，并非常有效地做到这一点。我想应该指出，我们在这里有点模糊，也许没关系，在数据库和数据库管理系统之间。
Oh, yeah, that's a good point. In some way like database. Yeah, go ahead. Oh, I was just gonna say that the, you know, it's kind of a whole package, right? Yeah, but in some ways, like a database is, is a theoretical design thing, right? Like, you know, for a relational database, I'm defining, you know, here's my schema, here are my relations, here are my constraints and like you know i want some physical implementation of that but you could arguably have different front ends that handle it differently based on
哦，是的，那是一个很好的观点。在某种程度上，像数据库。是的，请继续。哦，我只是想说，你知道，它是一个完整的包，对吧？是的，但在某些方面，像数据库是一个理论设计的东西，对吧？就像，你知道，对于关系数据库，我正在定义，你知道，这是我的模式，这是我的关系，这是我的约束，而且，你知道，我想要某种物理实现，但你完全可以说有不同的前端，根据
like how stuff is getting put in or taken out but in reality i don't know of anyone who does that for any practical reasons typically you have one database management system which is also managing kind of like the database the back end um but database management system is where things like what jason was talking about like observing usage patterns and deciding what to go ahead and pull out a priori you know say like oh i know you might going to look at this next that would be something that the management system would be handling versus like the database itself may have less of an influence on that. Yeah, that makes sense. I don't know. That may be arbitrary.
东西是如何放入或取出的来以不同的方式处理它，但实际上，我不知道有谁出于任何实际原因这样做。通常你有一个数据库管理系统，它也在管理某种像数据库后端的东西，但数据库管理系统是像杰森所说的那样，观察使用模式并决定先验地提取什么，你知道，说，哦，我知道你接下来可能会看这个，那将是管理系统会处理的事情，而数据库本身对那个的影响可能较小。是的，这很有道理。我不知道。那可能是随意的。
The other thing that is really good for a database is, initially you start off storing data, retrieving data, but then as you have more users and more data, you want to do analysis. You want to say, what kind of trends do I have? How many users are visiting my website each day? Is it growing or shrinking? What regions? And the more ways you want to slice and dice and analyze your numbers the more you're going to want them to be in a database which it's kind of understood how to write queries to do this otherwise you end up re-implementing a lot of that yourself over your whatever your other implementation of storing your data is. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, a lot of the database-driven languages are designed for people
数据库真正擅长的另一件事是，最初你开始存储数据，检索数据，但随着你有更多的用户和更多的数据，你想要做分析。你想要说，我有什么样的趋势？每天有多少用户访问我的网站？它是在增长还是在萎缩？什么地区？你想要切片和分析你的数字的方法越多，你就越希望它们在数据库中，这在某种程度上是理解如何编写查询来做这件事的，否则你最终会重新实现很多你自己关于存储数据的其他实现。是的，这很有道理。是的，很多数据库驱动的语言是为那些
who want to extract meaningful information from their data. And yeah, you're going to have to be re-implementing that, which is not fun. Yeah, another one, we'll just kind of round this out, is validation. So there's a lot of database management system support triggers. So, in other words, if, say, you know, say an entry is written for a credit card transaction and it links to some credit card, but then that credit card isn't there, then what that means is clearly some system has made some mistake because it's tried to reference a credit card that doesn't exist. So you could have some trigger that says,
想要从他们的数据中提取有意义信息的人设计的。而且是的，你将不得不重新实现它，这并不有趣。是的，另一个，我们只是把这个总结一下，是验证。所以有很多数据库管理系统支持触发器。所以，换句话说，如果，比如，你知道，假设一个条目是为信用卡交易编写的，它链接到某张信用卡，但那张信用卡不存在，那么这意味着显然某个系统犯了一些错误，因为它试图引用一张不存在的信用卡。所以你可以有一些触发器说，
when I see a credit card ID for a credit card that's not in the credit card, you know, part of the database, then, you know, send an email or page somebody or something like that. Also, you could do client side. Well, I don't know if you'd really call it client side, but you could do sort of immediate validation, right? So if somebody tries to insert a record, you know, without inserting its sister record that it's joined with, or some other kind of validation. If somebody puts a negative age in the age column or something like that, then it just
当我看到一张不在数据库信用卡部分的信用卡的信用卡ID时，那么，你知道，发送一封电子邮件或呼叫某人或类似的事情。此外，你可以在客户端做。嗯，我不知道你是否真的称它为客户端，但你可以做某种即时验证，对吧？所以如果有人试图插入一条记录，你知道，而不插入它连接的姐妹记录，或者其他某种验证。如果有人在年龄列中放入一个负数年龄或类似的东西，那么它只是
won't accept that operation. It says, hey, if you're going to put an age, it has to be at least zero. It has to be a non-negative number. So a lot of these types of validation, this type of validation logic is very easy to do. They make it very easy and practical, which is these are all things that you'd have to write manually in C++ or something like that if you're writing your own database. So we're going to start talking about the different types of databases. And one thing to mention as a side note, and it's a very detailed subject, so maybe we'll just kind of gloss over it, is the issue of consistency. So this is when a single person is updating, or a single user computer process is updating your database. You typically don't run into this problem,
不会接受那个操作。它说，嘿，如果你要输入一个年龄，它必须至少是零。它必须是一个非负数。所以很多这些类型的验证，这种验证逻辑非常容易做到。它们使它变得非常容易和实用，而这些都是如果你自己编写数据库，你必须在C++或类似的东西中手动编写的所有事情。所以我们将开始谈论不同类型的数据库。有一件事要作为旁注提及，这是一个非常详细的主题，所以也许我们只是略过它，那就是一致性的问题。所以这是当一个人正在更新，或者单个用户计算机进程正在更新你的数据库时。你通常不会遇到这个问题，
but it's when you have multiple users that you begin to have an issue. And consistency, one, the kind of gold standard, I guess, is ACID compliance, which is atomicity or atomic things consistent, which is I kind of grouped them all in together but i guess consistency is one part of it isolation and durability and we won't go through what each one means you can read about it and they have very precise definitions um but these are basically that what happens what are the guarantees i can say about when i successfully insert a row or update, what do I know has happened or not happened? So like, if you think about a bank, both my wife and I can go use the same ATM card,
但当你拥有多个用户时，你就会开始遇到问题。而一致性，一种，我想是黄金标准，是ACID合规性，即原子性或原子事物一致性，这我有点把它们都归在一起了，但我猜一致性是其中的一部分，隔离性和持久性，我们不会逐一解释每个词的意思，你可以阅读它，它们有非常精确的定义，嗯，但这些基本上是，我能对当我成功插入一行或更新时，我能说出什么保证，我知道发生了什么或没发生什么？所以，如果你想到一家银行，我和我妻子都可以去使用同一张ATM卡，
or, you know, my ATM card, her ATM card, which linked to the same account. And we can try to draw money at the same time. And the system needs to be very carefully set so that we aren't able to draw, you know, both the full amount or the bank will end up giving us too much money. And so in that case, you want to make sure that you understand what happens when there are parallel transactions occurring. Right. I mean, in Patrick's case, the transactions are happening very slowly. But here, I mean, there's just there could be millions, maybe billions of people accessing your database. And so it becomes very likely that two people try to delete the same thing at exactly the same time. And so that could be very difficult to handle, right?
或者，你知道，我的ATM卡，她的ATM卡，它们链接到同一个账户。我们可以尝试同时取钱。系统需要非常小心地设置，以便我们不能同时提取，你知道，全额，否则银行最终会给我们太多的钱。所以在那情况下，你要确保你理解当有并行事务发生时会发生什么。对。我的意思是，在帕特里克的例子中，事务发生得非常慢。但在这里，我的意思是，可能有数百万，也许数十亿人正在访问你的数据库。所以很有可能两个人试图在完全相同的时间删除相同的东西。所以这可能非常难以处理，对吧？
Or two people try to insert the same thing at the same time. Or you're in the middle of an operation and the power goes out. These are all just very difficult things to handle, and a lot of thought has gone into sort of how to deal with that. So, yeah, there's many different types of databases. Getting back to Patrick's point, this is sort of more we're going to talk about the actual database side,
或者两个人试图在同一时间插入相同的东西。或者你正在进行操作，电源断了。这些都是非常难以处理的事情，而且人们已经投入了大量的思考来处理这些问题。所以，是的，有许多不同类型的数据库。回到帕特里克的一点，这更多的是我们将谈论实际的数据库方面，
and then we'll get to some implementations of management systems later on. But the two that I think most people will be familiar with are relational databases and then everything else, which everything else you've heard maybe NoSQL databases, but basically that's sort of a catch-all for just a varied assortment of other databases. And it just happens that because of changes in computation and networking and in sort of the Moore's Law kind of fading and things becoming more distributed, the NoSQL databases have become much more important. And so we'll cover those in general. So why don't you go first? What's a SQL database?
然后我们稍后会谈到一些管理系统的实现。但我认为大多数人会熟悉的两个是关系数据库，然后是其他所有东西，其他所有东西你可能听说过NoSQL数据库，但基本上那是对各种其他数据库的统称。而且恰好因为计算和网络的变化，以及摩尔定律的某种消退和事物变得更加分布式，NoSQL数据库变得更加重要。所以我们将概括地涵盖这些。那么你先来吧？什么是SQL数据库？
I mean, I think if you know any kind of database, this is the one you're likely to know. So SQL is the structured query language. This is where you see select, star from the table name, where, some limits you put on the query, and the query runs. And similarly, there's a schema associated with it. So when you create tables and you have constraints, and some of this is particular to a database management system, and some of it is part of a standards-based language that you can use. And there are all sorts of things which support SQL-like languages. So you can write a query like what I just described, select star from users where creation date is yesterday.
我的意思是，我认为如果你知道任何类型的数据库，这很可能是你知道的那一个。所以SQL是结构化查询语言。这就是你看到select，star from表名，where，你对查询设置的一些限制，然后查询运行。同样，有一个与它关联的模式。所以当你创建表并且你有约束时，其中一些是特定于数据库管理系统的，其中一些是基于标准的语言的一部分，你可以使用它。而且有各种各样的东西支持类似SQL的语言。所以你可以编写一个像我刚才描述的查询，select star from users where creation date is yesterday。
Something like that. It's a very common way. A lot of things use this because it's a a very straightforward notion um but ultimately underlying it the relational part says how do how do i provide links between two tables um and it gets into what you'll you'll hear the term normalized and denormalized data and patterns for that so you want to be efficient in saying like if i have a whole if i have a teacher and a teacher has a bunch of students uh the students also have classes right you can try to model you know kind of each row contains all the data necessary but that's you're replicating a lot of information and you're
类似的东西。这是一种非常常见的方式。很多东西使用这个，因为它是一个非常直接的概念，嗯，但最终其底层，关系部分说明了如何，我如何在两个表之间提供链接，而且它涉及到你会听到的术语，规范化和非规范化数据以及其模式。所以你想要在说，比如如果我有一个，如果我有一个老师，而老师有一堆学生，嗯，学生也有班级，对吧？你可以尝试建模，你知道，某种程度上每一行都包含所有必要的数据，但那是你在复制大量信息，而且你
not representing the relationships there that there is a a teacher entity and a teacher entity is linked to student entities and linked to class entities and those relationships can be one-to-one many-to-one one-to-many many-to-many right you can kind of have constraints about what those things are like and keys that index into other tables so like a student id is the key and that might be what you would store in a class roster a teacher students and then there might be like a student record in a class roster, a teacher's students, and then there might be like a student record which is keyed by student ID and contains like the student's address and their billing status, that kind of stuff.
没有代表那里的关系，即有一个老师实体，而一个老师实体链接到学生实体，并链接到班级实体，而这些关系可以是1对1，多对1，1对多，多对多，对吧？你可以有关于这些东西是什么的约束，以及索引到其他表的键，所以比如学生ID是键，那可能就是你会存储在班级名册中的东西，一个老师的学生，然后可能像班级名册中的学生记录，一个老师的学生，然后可能像一个学生记录，它是以学生ID为键，并包含像学生的地址和他们的账单状态，那种东西。
And that is the traditional relational database structure, and you use SQL to interface and do what joins between these tables to construct the information necessary to get the query to run and the information that you are looking for out whether it be to look up a specific set of information or do analysis yeah definitely um yeah so a lot of um a lot of sq SQL and these kind of things, as Patrick was saying around this concept of IDs and doing joins. So, for example, you might have, say, a student's table, and it has a record for every student, but then that record also has what's called a unique ID. So, you know, Patrick and all of his grades and things like that might be in the student table and might be given an ID of like 123.
而这就是传统的关系数据库结构，你使用SQL来接口并做这些表之间的连接，以构建获取查询运行所需的必要信息，以及你正在寻找的信息，无论是查找特定的信息集还是做分析。是的，绝对，嗯，是的，所以很多，嗯，很多SQL和这些类型的东西，正如帕特里克所说，围绕着ID和做连接的概念。所以，例如，你可能有一个，比如学生表，它为每个学生都有一个记录，但那个记录也有所谓的唯一ID。所以，你知道，帕特里克和他所有的成绩之类的事情可能都在学生表中，并可能被赋予一个像123的ID。
And then in, say, the classroom table, you might have each classroom also has its own unique ID. And the classroom has a list of students. But instead of putting the whole student record there, you could just refer to them by ID. So you could say, okay, in this class, there is student 123, student 456, so on and so forth. And then you could take that list of IDs and go back to the student table and say, okay, who is 123? And so this sort of breaks a lot of these circular dependencies
然后在，比如，教室表中，你可能每个教室也有它自己的唯一ID。而教室有一个学生列表。但与其把整个学生记录放在那里，你只需通过ID引用它们。所以你可以说，好的，在这个班级里，有学生123，学生456，以此类推。然后你可以获取那个ID列表，回到学生表说，好的，谁是123？所以这在某种程度上打破了许多这些循环依赖
or having to have the same information twice is by storing a lot of these almost like pointers. And there's very efficient ways of looking up things by their ID and things like that. So then we get to every other kind of database in the world as it seems now. So yeah, NoSQL databases have really taken over for a variety of reasons. There's several of them. One is KeyValueStore, and this is the oldest. I mean, this might even predate SQL databases.
或者不必两次拥有相同的信息，是通过存储很多这些几乎像指针的东西。而且有非常有效的方法通过它们的ID查找东西之类的。所以我们到了世界上所有其他类型的数据库，看起来现在是这样。所以是的，NoSQL数据库确实因为各种原因接管了。有几个。一个是键值存储，这是最古老的。我的意思是，这甚至可能早于SQL数据库。
But this is a very simple idea. Imagine if you had a SQL table with just one column. Well, you had, I guess, two columns, the ID and then some other column. So that's all a key value store is. You give it the key and it spits back the value. And so you can think of this almost like a cache. Most caches are key value stores. And so even though it's very intuitive, it's one of the oldest types of databases, it actually proves to be very effective. There's something called a column family database, which is similar to a key value store, but the idea is for one key, there may be many values. So again, if you look at, say, a SQL database, you have, you know, a student record,
但这只是一个非常简单的想法。想象一下如果你有一个只有一列的SQL表。好吧，我想，你有两列，ID和另一列。所以这就是键值存储的全部内容。你给它键，它吐回值。所以你可以认为这几乎像一个缓存。大多数缓存是键值存储。所以即使它非常直观，它是最古老的数据库类型之一，它实际上被证明非常有效。有一种东西叫列族数据库，它类似于键值存储，但想法是对于一个键，可能有许多值。所以再次，如果你看，比如SQL数据库，你有，你知道，学生记录，
and you might have the key for that record, and then a bunch of other columns with information, just student name, you know, grades, so on and so forth a column family is very similar where you have you know like a student ID and then you also have you know some more a set of values about that student the only difference is in sequel the idea is the ID itself itself doesn't contain any information. So in other words, you know, like Patrick might be given an ID of 123, but that, like the application shouldn't know or care about that ID. It's just a number that is used in the database to, you know, look up Patrick. And it's even, most of the time it's given by the database. The application can't
而且你可能有那个记录的键，然后是一堆其他列的信息，只是学生姓名，你知道，成绩，以此类推。列族非常相似，你有，你知道，像学生ID，然后你也有，你知道，更多，一组关于那个学生的值。唯一的区别是，在SQL中，想法是ID本身不包含任何信息。所以换句话说，你知道，比如帕特里克可能被赋予一个123的ID，但那个，像应用程序不应该知道或关心那个ID。它只是数据库中用来，你知道，查找帕特里克的一个数字。而且它甚至，大多数时候它是数据库给出的。应用程序不能
assign that unique ID. And the IDs are chosen in a way which make indexing and things like that really easy. With a column family or a key value store, the assumption is that the key itself is important. So in other words, I'm not going to say Patrick is 123. You know, Patrick, the name, could be the key. And then the value is all the information on Patrick. And so you can actually have multiple keys with the same name. And, you know, there could be collisions there that have to get sorted out. You know, depending on how the management system works, the key might
分配那个唯一ID。而且ID的选择方式使得索引之类的事情变得非常容易。对于列族或键值存储，假设是键本身很重要。所以换句话说，我不会说帕特里克是123。你知道，帕特里克，名字，可以是键。然后值是关于帕特里克的所有信息。所以你实际上可以有多个名字相同的键。而且，你知道，那里可能会有必须解决的冲突。你知道，取决于管理系统如何工作，键可能
have to be unique. But yeah, the idea there is with the column families at the key and the key value stores that the key matters. Thirdly, there's a document store. And this is something that's becoming much more common recently.
必须是唯一的。但是的，那里的想法是，对于列族和键值存储，键很重要。第三，有文档存储。这是最近变得越来越常见的东西。
But the idea of the document store is that it's much more unstructured so if you were to think of say XML or JSON or something like that you can represent a variety of things in XML or JSON and you could even you could have a collection of JSON objects which have different topologies right so in other words like I could have one document in a document store which is the Patrick document and has like a list of Patrick's grades but I could have another document in the same database which has you know Jason
但文档存储的想法是它更加非结构化，所以如果你要考虑，比如XML或JSON或类似的东西，你可以在XML或JSON中表示各种各样的东西，你甚至可以，你可以有一个JSON对象集合，它们有不同的拓扑结构，对吧？所以换句话说，比如我可以有一个文档存储中的一个文档，它是帕特里克文档，并且有像帕特里克的成绩列表，但我可以在同一个数据库中有另一个文档，它有，你知道，杰森
and has doesn't have. That's something completely different for whatever reason. So in the case of Document Store, it's much looser. And just through advances in the technology and also computation power growing, we're able to have these more sophisticated database management systems
并且没有。那是因为某种原因完全不同的东西。所以在文档存储的情况下，它松散得多。而且仅仅通过技术的进步以及计算能力的增长，我们能够拥有这些更复杂的数据库管理系统
that can do all the things we talked about, the validation, the indexing, the caching, without having such a tight schema as we do with SQL. So even with such a loose schema as you have in a document store, you know, given the right kind of resources and things like that, you can still do a lot of the things that we said at the beginning. All right, so now quickly as like an overcap, we'll talk about because you may be thinking of a given database and like, oh, I wonder what it is,
它能完成我们讨论过的所有功能，比如验证、索引、缓存，而且不需要像 SQL 那样严格的模式。所以，即使是在文档存储这种模式非常宽松的情况下，只要有合适的资源，你仍然可以实现我们开头提到的很多功能。好了，现在我们快速回顾一下，因为你可能正在考虑某个特定的数据库，心里在想，不知道它是什么，
or maybe we just mentioned some databases you might be interested in looking up. We're going to kind of go through some breakdown of the various implementations of the databases and some examples if we can give and what kind they are so first first kind of section is the lightweight embedded you know probably only runs on one computer database and the first example that is very popular is sequel light s S-Q-L-I-T-E, SQLite. And it is a SQL implementation, a relational database. But it can be even embedded in your program and is super simple to use.
或者我们刚才提到的某些数据库你可能想去查一查。我们将梳理一下各种数据库的实现方式，如果可以的话，还会给出一些例子，说明它们属于哪种类型。首先，第一类是轻量级嵌入式数据库，通常只在一台计算机上运行。第一个非常流行的例子是 SQLite（S-Q-L-I-T-E）。它是一个 SQL 实现，属于关系型数据库，但它可以嵌入到你的程序中，使用起来非常简单。
And kind of one of those things, if you start to get any sort of complicated data you're trying to store in your program, you should consider using this instead because it may make your life uh you know easier and it's it's quite efficient it doesn't take you don't have to run separate server uh and connect to it you um it kind of reduces the complexity of that that's necessary yeah i mean i think it's even built into some languages like i know python has sqlite built in i didn't know that. Yeah, you really don't have to do a lot of work to get it up and running. And I know Jason's used BerkeleyDB for stuff, right? I think you were talking about that. Yeah, BerkeleyDB is pretty cool.
这属于那种情况：如果你开始处理任何复杂的存储数据，你应该考虑使用它，因为它会让你的生活更轻松，而且它非常高效。你不需要运行单独的服务器并连接它，它降低了必要的复杂性。是的，我的意思是，我觉得它甚至内置在一些语言中，比如我知道 Python 就内置了 SQLite，我之前不知道。是的，你确实不需要做太多工作就能让它运行起来。我知道 Jason 用过 BerkeleyDB，对吧？我想你之前提到过。是的，BerkeleyDB 很不错。
Actually, I'll list another one on here, MapDB. And so these are also embedded. So as Patrick was saying, let's say you have some program that you're writing and you need to store some kind of configuration. Like the people, you know, what sounds the people want when they log in or, you know, it's some kind of music app, you know, or sorry, some kind of like music creation program. You know, what settings do they want their piano set at? These kind of configuration things, these embedded databases are great for that because you could just load it from a file store to a file. It could be part of your program.
其实，我还要列举另一个，MapDB。这些也都是嵌入式的。正如 Patrick 所说，假设你正在编写一个程序，需要存储一些配置信息。比如人们登录时想要的音效，或者某种音乐创作程序，他们希望钢琴设置成什么样？对于这类配置信息，这些嵌入式数据库非常适合，因为你可以直接从文件加载或存储到文件，它可以成为你程序的一部分。
You don't have to go phone home or something like that, contact a server or anything. So SQLite is a relational database, so it uses SQL with the structure tables and things like that. If you just want a key value store, so again, you look up a key, you get a value. Then you can use BerkeleyDB or MapDB. BerkeleyDB is written in C++, but there are bindings for a bunch of different languages. Map DB is a lot better, but it's written in Java.
你不需要去连接服务器或做类似的事情。SQLite 是一个关系型数据库，所以它使用带有结构化表等的 SQL。如果你只需要一个键值存储，即通过键查找值，那么你可以使用 BerkeleyDB 或 MapDB。BerkeleyDB 是用 C++ 编写的，但有许多不同语言的绑定。MapDB 要好得多，但它是用 Java 编写的。
So the quick answer is if you're using Java, use Map DB. If you're using any other language, use Berkeley DB. Next, we move up the scale to something that you would probably be running on a server. But if you wanted something really fast, and you know, your data size was kept under control, but you wanted it to run in memory, you get to your next set of databases, the one that is you see all the time on like hacker news and other websites is Redis. Is that how you say it? I actually don't know. But I think so okay it's like all these names i only ever read them so actually i just happened to just total coincidence
所以简单的回答是：如果你使用 Java，就用 MapDB；如果你使用任何其他语言，就用 BerkeleyDB。接下来，我们升级到你可能会在服务器上运行的数据库。但如果你想要速度非常快，数据量可控，并且希望它在内存中运行，那么就到了下一组数据库。你在 Hacker News 和其他网站上经常看到的一个是 Redis。是这样读吗？我其实不知道。但我想应该是吧，好吧，这些名字我通常只读过，所以这纯属巧合，
i went to a redis uh meetup and and it is redis at least the people there all said redis all right so yep redis and that's a key value store so So it's gaining a lot of popularity recently. It's pretty lightweight and it's really fast if your data size is in the range that you can hold in main memory. Yeah, keep in mind like it, once you shut down Redis or even like periodically, it saves to disk. So it's not like, it's not truly in memory
我去过一个 Redis 聚会，那里的人都读 Redis。好吧，那就是 Redis，它是一个键值存储。它最近越来越受欢迎。它非常轻量，如果你的数据量在内存能容纳的范围内，它速度非常快。是的，记住，一旦你关闭 Redis，或者即使是定期，它也会保存到磁盘。所以它并不是完全只存在于内存中，
where you shut down the computer and you lose everything. But the idea is, yeah, at any given time, all of the data is in memory. Yep. Another one is memcached. I think that's how you say it. Or do you just say memcached? I say memcached. Really?
那种关机后所有数据都会丢失的内存数据库。但它的理念是，在任何给定时间，所有数据都在内存中。是的。另一个是 memcached。我想是这样读的，还是直接读 memcached？我读 memcached。真的吗？
I heard people say memcached, but okay. It could be. I mean, actually, I've only said it. I've never heard anyone else say it now that I think about it. Okay. So I don't know this is another one you hear and this is often when you hear about somebody's having a performance problem uh with their sql database right we'll talk about some in a second but you
我听过别人读 memcached，但好吧。有可能。其实我只读过这个词，现在想想，我从来没听过别人读它。好吧。所以我不知道，这是你经常听到的另一个词，通常当你听到有人说他们的 SQL 数据库有性能问题时，我们会稍后讨论一些，但你
know they're having problems because there's some specific data that it just has a higher access rate or different pattern than what you know sql stuff was built to handle. And you'll hear about people talking about this as a way to store data in memory and have very fast access times and kind of alleviate some of the slowness that can happen if you have too many concurrent users to a SQL database. Right. Like in contrast with Redis, memcached, when you shut down the machine,
知道他们遇到问题是因为某些特定数据的访问频率更高，或者访问模式与 SQL 原本的设计不同。你会听到人们谈论用它作为一种在内存中存储数据并实现极快访问速度的方法，从而缓解当 SQL 数据库并发用户过多时可能出现的缓慢问题。没错。与 Redis 相比，memcached 在你关闭机器时，
it does destroy the database. So the idea with the memcached, as Patrick was saying, is to use to augment another database. And it's for when that database is too slow. So you can imagine things that would be good for Memcached should be the front page of your website, things like that. And there's a lot of, if you use Ruby on Rails or if you use a lot of these content management systems, most of them will support memcached.
它确实会销毁数据库。所以正如 Patrick 所说，memcached 的理念是用来增强另一个数据库，用于那个数据库太慢的情况。你可以想象，适合 Memcached 的场景应该是你网站的首页之类的内容。如果你使用 Ruby on Rails 或者很多内容管理系统，它们大多数都支持 memcached。
And things like the front page of your website, they will put in main memory. I have no idea why I've heard people say memcached before because it looks like it's just memcached you're right oh is did you actually find a pronunciation so well i i'm trying to look for it so i see other people saying that they hear it as memcached um i don't know i i can't find a definitive answer i think you know so memcache d makes the most sense because i think it's a memcache daemon i think that's where the name comes from yes but i just i don't know i mean just because it makes sense it doesn't mean it's right so it's kind of silly but i remember when linux was first kind of well when i first started encountering it and nobody knew
像网站首页这样的内容，它们会放在主内存中。我完全不知道为什么我之前听过别人读 memcached，因为它看起来就是 memcached。你是对的，你找到发音了吗？我正在试着查一下，我看到其他人说他们听到的也是 memcached。我不知道，我找不到确切的答案。我觉得 memcache d 最合理，因为我认为它是 memcache daemon，我想名字就是这么来的。是的，但我不知道，仅仅因为它合理并不意味着它是对的。这有点傻，但我记得 Linux 刚出现时，或者我刚接触它时，没人知道
exactly how to say it like none of my friends um this is before youtube videos i guess so you couldn't look on youtube videos for yeah i remember when people called it linux yeah right exactly linux linux linux it's like people would say weird stuff i've never heard that one uh yeah i heard all sorts of strange things linux but now i guess there's so much video right like i don't know or what exactly happened but it's i've never heard people say anything other than linux anymore yeah that's a good point i'm not sure what caused the transition maybe it is you know maybe that's real that would be really interesting if youtube like homogenized you know language that that uh that'd be like something really
到底该怎么读。我的朋友们都不知道，这还是在 YouTube 视频出现之前，所以你没法在 YouTube 上查。是的，我记得人们叫它 Linux，没错，就是 Linux。人们会读得很奇怪，我从来没听过那个读法。是的，我听过各种奇怪的读法，但现在我想视频太多了，我不知道发生了什么，但我再也没听过人们读 Linux 以外的读法了。是的，这是个好观点。我不确定是什么导致了这种转变，也许 YouTube 真的统一了语言，那将是非常
interesting to study i'm sure some linguist is looking into that right now using disk-based server databases yeah that's right so the most obvious one you know first ones you think about are mysql sql server post postgres um you know these are ones that a lot of people have heard are MySQL, SQL Server, Postgres. These are ones that a lot of people have heard of. They've been around for a long time. They're some free, some paid, some varying licenses. Yeah, can you explain? Do you understand the MySQL license?
有趣的研究课题，我相信现在肯定有语言学家在研究这个问题。使用基于磁盘的服务器数据库，是的，没错。所以最明显的，你首先想到的是 MySQL、SQL Server、Postgres。这些是很多人都听说过的。它们已经存在很长时间了。有些是免费的，有些是付费的，有些有不同的许可证。是的，你能解释一下吗？你了解 MySQL 的许可证吗？
No, I don't understand. No, no, don't ask me about any of that. I have no idea. It looks to me like if you use the mysql you know client even the client then you have to pay them money that's how i read it but uh but that can't be true so i don't know there are people's whole jobs who are like around optimizing and selecting what the differences are between the different database i'm not that person i appreciate those people but i'm not them yeah definitely there's a whole art to making my sql run the way you want it to giving your data and patrick and i are very happy to let people much more qualified than we are do that.
不，我不了解。不，别问我这些。我完全不知道。在我看来，如果你使用 MySQL 客户端，即使只是客户端，你也得付钱给他们，我是这么理解的。但这不可能是真的，所以我不知道。有些人专门从事优化工作，并选择不同数据库之间的区别，我不是那个人。我很感激这些人，但我不是他们。是的，确实，让 MySQL 按照你的要求运行，并处理你的数据是一门艺术，Patrick 和我非常乐意让比我们更有资格的人去做这件事。
That is true. Yeah, so those are in the SQL family. If you're interested in the column family, which, again, just a reminder, that's the key value where there could be multiple values, right? So, you know, column family, if you have just one column in the column family then you have a key value database so you think of the column family as being a superset of what a key value database can do um so in that category there's two big ones one is cassandra and the other is h base um the short story story is the reason why there's two, they use kind of different technologies for scaling.
确实如此。是的，这些属于 SQL 家族。如果你对列族感兴趣，再次提醒一下，那是键值存储，但可能有多个值。所以，如果你在列族中只有一个列，那么你就有了一个键值数据库。所以你可以把列族看作是键值数据库功能的超集。在这一类中，有两个大头，一个是 Cassandra，另一个是 HBase。简短的故事是，它们之所以有两个，是因为它们使用了不同的扩展技术。
So in other words, when you have to split the, to shard the database among, say, 10 or 100 computers, both each of those two, HBase and Cassandra, handle that differently. um let's just say the trade-off there is you know cassandra is easier to set up definitely if you're running on one machine cassandra is way easier to set up but even as you scale out it's it's the the setup and the maintenance is pretty easy but on the the flip side, if you do have performance issues, it can be kind of a nightmare.
换句话说，当你必须在比如 10 台或 100 台计算机之间对数据库进行分片时，HBase 和 Cassandra 处理的方式不同。我们只能说，其中的权衡是，Cassandra 更容易设置。如果你在一台机器上运行，Cassandra 绝对更容易设置，即使在你扩展时，设置和维护也相当容易。但另一方面，如果你确实遇到了性能问题，那可能会是一场噩梦。
That's just been my experience. HBase is harder to set up. It actually requires a lot of Apache libraries and services that you have to install manually, like Zookeeper. So you actually have to install Zookeeper, start a Zookeeper server, and then install HBase and get an HBase server. So this is actually two servers. So it's got overhead, but on the flip side,
这是我的经验。HBase 更难设置。它实际上需要很多 Apache 库和服务，你必须手动安装，比如 Zookeeper。所以你实际上必须安装 Zookeeper，启动一个 Zookeeper 服务器，然后安装 HBase 并获取一个 HBase 服务器。所以这实际上是两个服务器。所以它有开销，但另一方面，
it just seems like tuning and understanding what's going on is a lot easier with HBase. So that's column family and then for document store there's also a bunch of them my favorite is mongodb um i really think mongodb is very clever in their api i'm a big fan. I felt like, so they have this kind of cool sort of REST-based JSON API. They also have a good Java API. They are now, they've recently added full text indexing, which is pretty cool. So you can actually say this column, you know, if I want to be able to do like fuzzy text searches on this column, you can just annotate the column and boom, you get fuzzy text searches. So just to recap, like if, if the column was, you know, say, a web page, let's say let's say one column of your database or one document
在 HBase 中进行调优和理解发生了什么似乎容易得多。这就是列族。至于文档存储，也有很多，我最喜欢的是 MongoDB。我真的认为 MongoDB 的 API 非常巧妙，我是它的忠实粉丝。我觉得它们有一种很酷的基于 REST 的 JSON API。它们也有很好的 Java API。它们最近添加了全文索引，这非常酷。所以你实际上可以指定这一列，如果你想对这一列进行模糊文本搜索，你只需标注这一列，砰，你就能得到模糊文本搜索。所以回顾一下，如果这一列是，比如一个网页，假设你数据库的一列或一个文档
of your database is a website and all the XML or all the HTML for a website. You could just turn on this full-text indexing, and now you have a search engine over the whole web. Now, of course, you know, I mean, it's probably not optimized for that much data, but you get the idea. It's still pretty powerful. If you're building your own wiki or something like that,
是一个网站，包含了网站的所有 XML 或 HTML。你可以直接开启这个全文索引，现在你就拥有了一个覆盖整个网络的搜索引擎。当然，它可能没有针对那么大的数据量进行优化，但你明白我的意思。它仍然非常强大。如果你正在构建自己的维基百科之类的东西，
it's pretty cool to kind of get full-text searching for free. There's also RethinkDB, which we talked about at the beginning of the show. They're definitely new guys on the block, so they are iterating very quickly. I think it'll be pretty cool, but we'll have to sort of wait and see what they come out with in the future. It's still kind of early. All right. Well, that about wraps it up.
能免费获得全文搜索功能真的很酷。还有 RethinkDB，我们在节目开头提到过。他们绝对是新来的，所以他们迭代得非常快。我觉得这会很酷，但我们还得拭目以待他们未来会推出什么。现在还为时尚早。好了，差不多就是这样了。
I'm hoping that we didn't repeat too much of what we said when we did query languages, but that was like a long time ago. It's like 14 episodes ago. So hopefully there's not too much of a repeat. And thank you guys for all your emails get lots of on our Google Plus page or community I guess it's a community now people post in there and that's cool
我希望我们没有重复太多我们在查询语言那一期说过的内容，但那已经是很久以前的事了。那是 14 期节目之前了。所以希望没有太多的重复。感谢你们发来的所有邮件，我们在 Google Plus 页面或社区里收到了很多，我想现在它是一个社区了，人们在里面发帖，这很酷，
we see them even if we don't respond we do see them and emails to us are always appreciated yeah thanks Ash for your question that kind of got the whole episode kicked off so uh yeah definitely you know post on the community um if you have any questions or any any feedback or anything like that uh we do read it so um and it does give us a lot of inspiration for the show and things like that um uh we will definitely do swift as the next episode
即使我们不回复，我们也看到了。我们非常感谢发给我们的邮件。是的，感谢 Ash 的提问，这开启了整期节目。所以，一定要在社区里发帖，如果你有任何问题、反馈或类似的事情，我们确实会阅读。它确实给了我们很多节目灵感。我们下一期一定会做 Swift，
um we'll we'll have to uh beef up on our swift uh between between now and then uh but uh yeah i'm looking forward to that one so cool i think that's a wrap all right cool see you guys in a couple of weeks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们得在下次录制前加强一下 Swift 的知识。但我很期待那一期。太棒了，我想这就是结束了。好的，酷，几周后再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。